You
What happened?
What's going on? Are you guys getting a lot of background stuff? No, it's like it was my gox a lot because it's like a routing thing
Do I sound okay? Hi
Hello
I didn't swear I didn't swear I did no such thing
No such thing
What do you mean still muted why is the I lie to me you little saucy liars
Hi, yes
Jimmy Larry she she was live. What is the story? I know Ryan, you know
Um, what I what what I said when I was muted was I almost opened with a burp
But that wouldn't be very ladylike of me as I am a lady as you can tell by my attire. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
The highest form of lady. I'm a high lady if you will
Highest of esteemed
society
Everybody looks up to me. I'm essentially a queen really
Wearing philosophy may be extraordinarily capable of disagreeing with it. Oh, yeah, so you didn't you disagreed a lot with what he said
That's totally fine
Yeah, yeah, feel free to tweet at me your respective opinions of the book. I recommended
Yeah, exactly always look up to me because you're on your knees every time I pass by you must immediately
Drop to your knees. Um, also, I'm sorry if I was a minute late
I actually spilled water everywhere when I was filling up my cat's old hole water
fountain
In fact, I'm gonna drink my own water
Wait, I'm a woman. Yes. Hello. Could you not tell by my ample personality?
How much personality I have
Wow, I thought I was a Muppet doesn't mean you can be a I can be a womanly Muppet
You said let's not you were a bro. I am a bro. I'm your bro. She
Are you guys getting like my AC in the background I'm gonna be quiet for a second because it says my mic is picking it up
But I can't tell
You
Just a bit okay interesting I think I accidentally bumped something when I was um
Setting up string a
Little noise when we got a fix that right quick then let me put in my headphones and I will fix it
If I can put my headphones on the right ears, that would be great. How are you guys doing today?
How you guys doing oh
Yeah, I can hear that
I can't hear anything. It's happening
Yeah, you're doing okay. You got a free slurpee at 7-eleven. No way, bro
I'm jealous I am immensely jealous
White noise jump scare it's isn't reflecting for me
I
I'm so sorry
See if I put a little bit of a noise gate
Oh
You can kind of hear it when I talk oh
Yeah, it's 7-eleven day. I was really thinking I'm like, oh, it'd be funny if you got a slurpee on 7-eleven day and it is 7-eleven day
Yeah, let's beat myself up
Walk there got slurpees and left as you should thank you. Oh
I like
Gazoon died. I
Wish I was getting a
Oh, I saw someone ask earlier. What do I actually say to my therapist? I tell my therapist everything
I'm not I'm no liar
Yeah, I think I actually mess with my settings last night when I wasn't paying attention
Took off the noise gate I
Listed all of you by name
If you sent me a tribute as
As in like a little treat like a little like you sent me something on my throne that sort of not the other thing
Because that's bad YouTube. Please don't demonetize me. Um
She saw those two hundred percent
It's too really hot oh man
Yeah, I made a collage and I showed them all to her and I was like look what I got look what people got me Wow
He's like wow impressive
She was so impressed
No, that didn't happen
No, but I was kind of telling her how much help pretty much how
Don't let it get to your head how awesome you guys are and how much you help me and that I'm living my dream because of you
But don't you know let it get to your head or anything
Okay
Like I told her that you guys got me a vacuum and she was like what and then I was like, yeah
And I was like oh they got me this cool mixer thing and I showed her she's like what I'm like
Yeah, and they also got me some plushies and I showed her my bunny. That's next to me
She's like what the hell she's like what is the how does this work?
And I had explained to her the concept of streamers and
Surface talk to be in gen 2.0
Hi, she be it's fun time and welcome back to Elgin ring hi pretty
Oh
She's like man, I should change professional honestly, I think that thought crossed her mind for like a split second
She was like wait, so you put things up on a
throne
Wishlist and people buy them for you, and I'm like yeah people are just really nice. I don't even like
Have to do anything because she's like wow you have such a nice and caring community
They just like love to take care of you, and I'm like essentially yeah
Honestly a third certified therapist in gen 2 and make interesting it hey man
I was debating whether or not to get a psychology degree so I could be a therapist specifically for youtubers
Because it's a it's definitely a niche that that needs to be filled
Uh, there if was a youtuber would be interesting
It's really interesting
Oh, no, I had a good session
talked about you know how good i'm doing and that I thought I wouldn't be doing okay since I left my job
um mentally because it's a big transition
but um
Yeah, and I can't really handle change that well, but I'm like I've been fine. I've been so busy
I haven't even had time to be anxious about
Not having like a normal job
I need an accountant vtuber. I need an accountant vtuber who does my taxes because I'm a vtuber
Although I think my dad put me in touch with like an accountant. He's just like here you go
I don't want you evading taxes like a bunch of other e-girls. I'm like thanks dad. I appreciate you
Hello everybody
I'm professional
Dominatrices that's a funny way to spell that because nurses or have degrees. Oh, yeah a lot of people
That's just their night job and they have a day job
She I didn't tell her that I did tell her that you guys asked me to step on you and call you trash a lot
and she laughed at that
And then she said
Wait, uh, but my therapist is cool. She doesn't really uh
He doesn't like press me to pay or anything
But she's like wait, you don't have insurance anymore. Do you and I'm like well technically
I won't have insurance for like after three so I figured out I like I have insurance for like three months after I leave
and she's like
Uh, so she's like you should have them pay for your therapy because of all the stuff
That they make you do for them
And I started
cackling
so hard
She's just like I'm just saying I'm like, oh my god. No
Oh
She's just like, you know, it's a little thing
I
Yeah, everybody
My dad was just like hey, can you like
Get your harem to buy me bourbon?
I'm like what he's like. He sent me a picture. He's like
If the any of them have bourbon connects, let me know
I'll hit them up. Oh my dad. So you just want to like dox me and yourself. He's like wait never mind
Therapy bills on throne
Uh
We must keep afloat your mental stability return for more she be exactly. I'm literally needy streamer overdose overload whatever it's called
That's literally yeah
Become a connect for public
Yeah, I can't even hold on me look up the what is the bourbon that he said he's like I need you to find me this
I'm like, you think I have weight. You think I just have people who are like bourbon connoisseurs in my audience
I don't think so dad but go off
what do you say
it's uh
For any of you bourbon drinkers out there, I'll just tell you which one my dad is looking for
He wants a william
What does that say?
LaRue Wells, Kentucky straight bourbon whiskey
Uncut unfiltered
Why is it called that?
133.6 proof
limited edition barrel proof
Oh that one. Do you know that one? Do you guys actually know?
Chop that like I don't yeah, I don't know how much this is
He just sent me a picture. He didn't even send me the link
He's like
See if anyone is in the liquor business or has connects and what it would cost them because my dad likes to collect bourbon
My dad really like that says like that's my dad's special interest
Star Wars and collecting
Bourbon
My mom's is gardening my parents are very typical parents
My mom really likes flowers and birds and my dad likes bourbon and star wars
Yeah, it's not easy to get your hand out. Yeah. Yeah, I also I don't know alcohol at all
I'm just like I'll give me the fruitiest drink and I will have it
My model is stuff. Yeah, my model's stuck because I'm looking at when my dad texted me
The Venn diagram of bourbon drinkers and youtuber fans is two separate circles
I didn't know there's like bourbon
Streamers he was my dad was telling me he watched like bourbon streamers on twitch. It's so funny. My dad's cooler than me
I already know that
I'll speak in which I need to schedule
I want to do a street not a stream uh record. Maybe I'll do that when I'm gone
Yes
So what I'm so some of you who don't know. Hello. Hi. Um, I'm going to be gone for a week from the 18th to the 23rd
I'm going to go see my grandparents, but I wanted to go
Um, I wanted to record something in my absence
So I'm doing an ASMR and I was thinking if I was going to do a gameplay video, but now I'm I think I'm going to
Um, yeah, so week. I'm sorry. Um
I'm gonna do the video with my parents
And I'm gonna have them name v-tubers based off of their designs. So I'll probably grab like, uh,
Like obviously the v alert girls. I'll grab like, um, the people I've collabed with like
Mythos and like you may plus and then I'll grab like some like really popular indies just like iron mouse
um
And stuff and then some like haul alive girls obviously like chiara and nervisa and like some of the newer gen
So I and then see how my parents named them
I think my dad will just be like
I think both of my parents will just be like they have giant boobs
And this be so hung up on their outfits that they won't even
And I'm kind of nervous because I have to tell my my mom can be like my mom's very into fashion and so is my dad
But mostly my mom and she will like my mom again is very conservative
So she'll be like wow, she has her whole entire
Tire boobies out in her, you know, but does he whoa? Okay. This is this is what you do redacted
This is what you do. She me with your spare time
So I think it would be I just don't want my parents to roast people because they might roast people and I'm nervous
I might have to do disclaimer
Um, but yeah, maybe I'll do that
Or we'll set up a donkas. I think I'll do that
Um
Instead of because I was trying to think of like, okay, what's a gameplay video that I can do
I can't think of anything so
We're just gonna
Yeah
Feel like your mom would y'all at mercy given her vtuber lore
I'm not gonna make them look at the lore videos. I'm just be like, what is this outfit? Tell me what you think of it
I think my mom will really like straw knees outfit though and like theme. I think she'll think she's cute
And I think she'll like I I think I see will be my mom's favorite. I think mercy will be my dad's favorite
Father she be bourbon donathan one
maybe maybe I'll add that to like
My my donathan goals get my dad this particular bourbon
She means mom with the other girls now. Listen here young lady
I don't think my parents would like cute funny characters
Uh, at least go in a bit my sissac blumser model was like what is she naked?
I
Know I look I have I have a lot going on with my model. So I figured out I can probably make a toggle that takes off my
um
gag and my
ropes, but I've never
tried it
I could probably just sit here and do that right now actually
So mom is an ojisan and dad confirmed for a fifth. I know my mom is definitely an ojisan. My dad is definitely a senpai
Any Oscar? No, I will never ask my grandparents. No, no, no, no, I will never
I don't even still I just don't even know what I'm gonna tell my grandparents what I do for work. I'm gonna be like
um, I am currently um
Under mda so I can't talk about what I do. I work for the fbi
Can you make a toggle that covers your chest for youtube sama? Uh, I usually just put something over my chest
I know um, it's still being made my tan toggle and my cover-up toggle to close my shirt
Is being made so that'll happen
You handle a bunch of tiny rabbits pet shop owner
It's a secret. It's under ropes
Nd's a
Who's the danger sign?
Yeah, because that's what I when I ask people like what should I tell people that I do for my job
When they ask me people just say oh, you're with you work with a startup that's under nda and I'm like
Actually, but I'm gonna tell people that so that's what I think. What did I do the other day?
Who asked me?
I forget who I think maybe it was one of my former coworkers is like, oh, what are you doing now?
But they're like really normie. So I'm not gonna be like I'm a vtuber. I was just like, oh, I'm under nda and they're just like, whoa
Cool. Do you work for like a big huge tech corporation or the government? I'm like
No
Espionage
Feels like that excuse is good for a year, uh
Maybe
Say yes
Oh, yeah, what do you do in particular? Uh, I'm a hacker
I'm a puppeteer. Oh, yeah, I'd be I quit my my my job to become a ventriloquist and puppeteer
Secret agent chibi secret agent chibi
It's by master stroney, but there are a lot of people that are closet vtuber watchers. Are you please like
V tubing has a huge audience base, but I never ever run into other vtubing fans. I never do
Although I found out one of my co-workers was a vtuber
And that she was pretty popular and I was like
And uh, I can't remember if she came on my stream at one point
And then I also was just like you can't tell anybody
But then I I graduated my last persona so nobody knows who I am now because I didn't want because all my co-workers started finding out my last persona
Because one of my co-workers I was doing a um, what's it called?
A darkwood stream darkwood is a very good game by the way
Um, I don't know if I'd play that on stream though because I would prefer just kind of do that by myself
Um, because I sometimes I although I should just play I need to play a horror game. I need to just play a horror game. Um
Call
On a second this like I hate the it's like staticky because of my freaking
Go xlr. I'm just gonna sorry take that off for a moment
I
Can I
Sorry, I'm trying to open the interface. It's not popping up
Where is the interface? Hello
Is it just floating around where I can't see it?
I
Don't know
I'm so sorry. Yeah, that's all the fucking filters. I have to have on
I'm trying to do this because my my air conditioning goes off for like five or eight minutes and then it will turn off
So I try to do stuff in the span of time
There it is
I
Don't know if that does anything I can't tell
Okay, I can't does that sound better to you guys
The water I said my ac
My ac will kick on for like five to eight minutes. It sounds the same shit
Does that make a difference?
Bro, I'm trying my best out here. It keeps resetting
Bro, why are you filling up my chat? I get it
I
Thousand yards sir, you can hear it
I've tried to smashes me. Let's play along
Sounds okay
How about now is this sound good? I'm kidding. I know that sounds bad
Yeah, but I don't like it because I like nice clean crisp audio. You don't only hear the voices. That's fine
Well, look at you upgrading your tears. Thank you, sir
Let's give a round of applause
Hi, hi
Hi on my tv and I don't hear a thing besides my voice
Fan of the back is in d-vibes
All right, I don't I'm just not gonna freak with it anymore
I'm gonna hear them. Hello. I almost clicked exit on obs. Yeah, let's go
All right
Yeah, I want to do I want to do another big among us collab
I want to have the yume plus girls. I want to get uh nori and chai in there when obviously get some of my gen mates
Um, probably get mythos in there if they want to do that
What a way to start I've been I've been live for 30 minutes
Oh, look at the bromance in my chat. You guys are so sweet
It's always cute when you guys can recognize each other
You're like, uh, wait, I saw you in this person's stream and you're like, hey, it's adorable. I love the camaraderie the camaraderie
sorry
Do you think it would be smart to commit arson in my what?
Because someone broke the community. I don't maybe if you want. No, don't do that
Oh
Welcome
Comrade comrades comrades comrade
I know all of you
Just kidding
Gotta have bros around a charge the crystals
She be your she bees are I thought you too. Well, I think I'll be fine. I don't care. I just whatever, bro
I should probably eat something. I've only had applesauce today again
What's your name it's philip
I don't know. I'm just guessing
Like baby food. Yes. Hello. Hi
Hi
More food, I don't know what to eat. What am I wearing? You're just wearing boxer shorts
You should really put on some clothes. What if somebody walks in?
I have to drive home now so I have to turn off the stream. Oh be safe drive safely
Drive responsibly
I remember um you guys wear clothes if you just sit
Fuck naked
at your desk
No coverage on your dirty ass
And you watch my stream you got other issues
Anytime like I leave my friend's house. She's always just like um like olive because she lives far away from me
and then like the woods and
Oh pump fuck nowhere. She's like drive safe and I'm just like I'm gonna drive recklessly and dangerous
I'm on my boxer since I'm at work right now. Okay, go
You're at work and you're I'm confused. I hope you work from home because that's an HR event waiting to happen
The ghosts are you see you? All right. That's that's fine
At least we're at
All right, uh, what do you guys think I should eat do this in the chat
Yeah, I didn't
Sometimes I I stand up and I've I didn't want to accidentally like flash my therapist because I um a video call with her
So, um, I'm wearing shorts and a t-shirt, but before I wasn't wearing pants
Sushi. Oh, I haven't had sushi in so long
Plot twist bro is a model of some sort hence why they're working but hey, you know, that would be interesting
What you got in the frids condiments
You hate sushi, but you love fish. How what is wrong with you?
Oh, she got in the fridge is 80. I still haven't gone grocery shopping
What's the point of me growing grocery shopping if I'm gonna leave soon?
Mocky rolls be mad tasty. Yeah
I don't know if I should have sushi though because my as you guys know my tummy's been really upset lately
So it's been hard for me to have food
I think my meds are making me nauseous
She be it's been like, yeah, and I've been living off a door dash. What do you want from me?
What do you expect?
No, I don't have any disorder
You guys have seen my body I'm very healthy looking
Can you cook I don't have anything to cook get Chick-fil-A. I don't want Chick-fil-A
Your meal pepper. Yeah, whatever
Green tea and whenever eases the stomach
I'm happy
No, sometimes, um, I think ever since I start I could tell you what meds I'm on. I don't I don't really care
Um, so I started some for my skin because my skin has been breaking out real bad. I think because of the um
The heat and stuff and I don't know if I'm having I don't know if I'm having reaction to something
If I'm like allergic to something and it's making me break out. I don't know. Um, but so I'm on
Uh, it's an antibiotic to help with um that and it's doxicillin
But doxicillin makes you very have really gives you really bad. Um
What's it called acid reflux and then
Spiral lactone which is supposed to help with the hormone. I don't want to pronounce it with the hormonal aspect of acne
Can also make you really nauseous. So that's why eczema gain rise up. Um, I don't have eczema
Doxicillin doxicycline. I think I don't know doxicycline. Are you taking our food? Uh
I try to but it's been really hard to eat
Spiral love do people take that?
That are transitioning. I didn't know that
The med's gonna dox me
Um
But yeah, so I take that to like because sometimes because women's hormones are always like all over the place
Especially because our hormonal cycles are a month are a month long. So my doctors is like
Uh, yeah, it seems like you're and then like mercy
Um, was telling me that my symptoms sound like I have polycystic ovary syndrome like picos and I'm like, I don't
I don't know if I do
And she's like, I don't know. I should probably get the checked out on my facts
She's like, because you shouldn't be breaking on like you, right?
I should probably go to the doctor
It's part of a church. Oh, I didn't know that guys. I promise you I am a
This is
People are just like looking up and they're like, oh my god. She's not every woman or whatever the fuck
Uh
A lot of people take medications
Um
Cheapy go but I don't know what to eat and they have to order food and that means I have to go downstairs
I have to put on a bra. I have to put on better pants because they haven't shaved my legs
Because I'm too lazy to shave my legs
Got some people get prescriptive eye area for their heart. I didn't know that
I don't know what I'm craving. I'm too nauseous to crave anything
I
Have some yogurt or something. I usually have that. I don't have any yogurt. I told you I have condiments
In my fridge and that is all I have
I don't have ginger ale. I do have chicken noodle soup and I do have some oyster crackers
Huh, yeah, I'll have some chicken noodle soup
I forgot I had a can of that. Hold on. Let me go
No oatmeal. I think I have oatmeal. I don't know. It probably has like weevils in it or something because I haven't touched it in a while
Um, my stomach is very sensitive in general because I get I have gherd so
In the doxocycline just makes it worse
I hate having acne, but it's actually going away. It's really awesome. It's only been like two weeks and I'm like
Holy shit. Yay. I don't look like a freaking nugget of leprosy. Not that I did before but you know women leave mind
I just blow stuff out of proportion
I just feel like I got like one sit on my face and I think I'm dying. Um
Sorry, I'm far away from my computer
Chicken noodle soup
I think I don't put a can in the microwave
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. Everybody calm down. I can't even see the chat
Where is my pot
As in a pan not that
Devils lettuce you guys are gonna take a lot of the things I say in this true modic context. I know how you guys are
Don't spread any rats you bitches
I'm gonna nuke the boy
Um
Oh, yeah, hi tola I saw you briefly ever want to say hi
Um, what am I doing? Oh, yeah, I'm heating up soup
how do I
I forgot how to work by other for a second
Oh
Oh my god it's spilling everywhere. Is this good still? Does this go? It smells like cat food
I can't tell if it says it's good until November 2nd 2023 or
The bit could you not eat my soup will be can you stop?
Will be trying to take my soup
He'll just suck his head in the pot because will be just like jumps on the freaking stove because he wants to burn his little
Poppins off. Let me see what you guys say. What do you want? So are you following me?
You're stalker. Just following me
Um takes long for canned soup to go bad. Maybe it because it says 25. So I'm assuming it's 2025
Can the microwave on Thomas what is next season say it close on over the floor
My clothes your clothes look really good, but they look even better on my floor
Ah
You let your cats on the countertop, um, so funny none of my cats before boomie and fia
were ever on the countertop
But boomie is a menace to society and even taught reina to get up on the counter
So now reina thinks you can get up on the counter
But boomie and fia go up in the counter and I tried I tried for so long. I did the tin foil
I did the spray them of water boomie did not give a fuck
So I gave up
Booby his name is in booby. It's boomie
boomie king of umashu
I've tried the last airbender then reina is just reina and then fia is fia the deathbed companion
Kins last a long time
You be a silicate. Are you eating my soup now?
I hear like some licking in the fucking background in this bitch is eating my chicken noodle soup. Don't lick your lips
Why did you do this?
I can't trust you with anything. Booby also steals my food a lot
Stop you can't just eat my soup
It's also on the hot stove bro. Why would you use you literally have a death wish?
Yeah, stop licking. He's like licking his lips all proud. I mean you can't have this
How much did you eat?
Oh damn it
There's cat hair on my stove
I'm very upset with you young man. Don't try to he's a headbutting me
And looking at me all cutely
What do you don't try to seduce me?
You know what you did
Why are you such a dork?
You look so proud of yourself that you were able to get some of my soup. I'm very upset with you
Um where I need a bowl
All right gotta guard my food. I'm sorry
Don't leave it
Fucking bitch, where's fia and reina? I don't even know where they are
But I'm cute boomie co-host
Booby my oh she will star
Okay, he's he's he's distracted by grooming himself
Oh
Do you like your harem because we are just like boomy
No, you guys aren't like boomy you guys actually
Provide for me and take care of me and are sweet and give me compliments. Well boomy just fucking eats my food
And also tries to kill himself so often by doing stupid stuff like hot jumping on a hot stove
He's really grooming himself. He's just sitting all cutely on the floor just like oh, that was a delicious meal
Our cats are fricks. No
No, that's rude. Don't say that. I love my cats
Boomy is just a menace sometimes, but he is my son. He's going through his terrible twos except he's a year old
Did you get something in your eye your eye is very winky
I'm so mad
I turn around this motherfucker is on my counter
Sticking his head in the pot of soup just eating it
Fia will do that too Fia has stolen a chicken nugget from me before boomy's stolen fries for me
They like they like fries a lot. I don't know boomy has stolen my chips
I'll be like eating. No, what was I I was eating like
Like, you know, there's like nacho fries from Taco Bell like a couple months ago
I was eating those and I'm like sitting on my living room floor just like watching tv
So I don't like spill anything anywhere and if I can if I do I can just like clean it up instead of on my couch
And I'm about to stick a fry in my mouth and boomy sticks his paw into on my hand and brings it towards him and then takes a bite
I'm just I'm literally just with my hand in the air frozen
So shocked that my son just took a bite of my fry
And grabbed my paw to deuce my paw used his paw to grab my hand to do so
Madam, can we have a streamer audio when you discipline a cat boy for behaving like boomy?
Maybe
It'll just be a bunch of just like
Get off the counter get down and me just shaking a water bottle
He's testing it for poison
No, see I throw hands on my cats and they did that
See, yeah, I'm throwing I'm about to throw paws boomy. Let's fight
Oh, I'm coming for you. You just head butted me
No, stop stop seducing me
Here have a toy
I even gave you treats this morning. Do you think you can steal my food?
Where's your sister
Oh
He ever really likes the cat tree that you guys got likes to lay in that factory often
Gotta cook off boomy spit you're disgusting
Oh
Yeah, he's very cute. He's very nice when he does it too. He doesn't like use his claws or anything. He like boomy boomy
Likes to stretch a whole line of turn around because I thought he hopped up on the fucking counter again
he likes to stretch up and like, um
Against your leg and reach up at you and be like hi
and
He knows the difference between like if my skin is exposed if I'm wearing like shorts or if I'm wearing pants
Because when he when I'm wearing pants he uses his claws because he thinks it won't hurt me
But then recently I've told him that it hurts and so now he stops using his claws when he asks for uppies. Yeah
Yeah, but we ask for uppies a lot
And then because then he'll he also just like soft paw
um
soft paw it
He never would do that when I was wearing shorts non-verbal boy
He's not a monster
But just a simple menace
I wish my cats would stop using their claws on my bed sheets. Yeah, um, fia likes to do that
My cat hates me just bites me. Oh, I'm sorry
I
Like make my cats don't don't bite me unless like
Uh, they miss when we're playing and they accidentally like
Although boomie used to like bite me a lot as a kitten, but that's because he's a kitten
boomie's still a kitten. Yeah, you know, I'm talking about you
He's like right behind me. Hi
What do you love to you think about ways to take my soup again?
Oh, you're just you're scratching my carpet. It's not a scratching board, but it's fun
I need to clip your claws
They're very sharp I haven't clicked on them in a month
Fia destroy a bad companion
Okay, this is for I don't hate cats but low key fear of them
So if a cat approaches me I'm likely to look at the owner like what is it doing? What is it?
It's their action mean. Uh, yeah cats body language is a lot
Harder to read than a dogs
Um, really you can tell how a cat is feeling by looking at how their tail is
similar to a dog, um
But like if their tail is up like a little flag that means they're like happy to see you if it's like kind of like
A little like medium that's like they're content if it's a little bit lower. They're just like chilling
But if it's like tucked almost like a dog and they're like very frightened
Are you biting my carpet?
I gave you a spring. Did you knock it under the freaking couch bro? Oh my god, there's like 50 spring like toy springs under my couch
Um, yeah, I tell a lot of gonna cat means irritation
They hate being stared at
I don't know I stare at my cats they they just like just chirp at me when I do
Because they like to stare at me because cats like to stare at you
They're not like dogs where they're like scared of eye contact and stuff. They just like to watch you
Cats wink. Yeah, they give you a little I call it little kitty kisses. I'm like, oh, did you just give me a kiss when they like slowly blink at you?
um
Yeah, they don't like yeah, you don't want to pet a cat if it shows you your spelly because for a cat and they roll over
Onto there. Why am I peeking?
What the hell
Bro, I'm getting pissed
At my microphone right now
I
Because that means they have all their weapons on display
That's so weird, why is my microphone doing that? I'm sorry. I'm just watching the levels
Start staring without blinking is an aggression thing for cats blinking is fine, but for long eye contact is so you get yeah, it's like a
Like dogs where they're like challenging
Boomi, what are you doing?
Now he's under my desk. Hi big man
um
Hello, what are you up to please don't
He's like, I think there's like a wrapper under my desk that he wants
He's just being nosy now. Okay, let me check on my soup
Soup time. Oh, are you following me? You can't have any mister
Do not pop off here or I swear to god you're gonna accidentally hurt yourself. Oh my gosh
He's looking at my soup like I'm about to feed him some food. He's like, oh
I dropped my oyster crackers
Can't
You want a cracker? Yeah, see it's not interesting to you like why are you trying to like get all excited over that?
Okay, I don't have any ginger ale but I do have um seltzer water
I don't have to drink soda too much
One of my cats like belly touches the other does oh, yeah, feel loves her belly rubs. She loves it
So does rena
Oh, it's hot. Oh, it's burn my tongue
Now we
Need to move my taser
And my taser's just on my desk
Put that over here
Do I have a single cat mother?
Why are you shouting?
Hot soup is hot. She discovers the worst. Shut up. It's got taste
Be like a hood rabbit catches you and tases you
Because she thinks you stole her something or whatever
She's just scared the fuck out of you during the collab
Is it taser or taser it's with an s but good question
I'm waiting for my soup to cool, but I'm sad. I put in my little oyster crackers because now they're gonna get soggy
No lasers with an s
ASMR you still should be soup, but you are not a cat
A hood rabbit chases you down and tases you because she thinks you're cute. There you go
Because we um
My mom because there's a lot of rabbits in the area
Uh for my parents live and they live on the edge of like really nice
Suburban area and then really bad
Area and so sometimes a rat my mom will see like rabbit. She's like, ah, it's a hood rabbit
Is there they from the hood? Although I'm literally I don't live remotely near the hood
Oh
Thank you
Boomi all right just heard you jump down from something. I hope you didn't walk on the fucking stove
You didn't okay good
Yeah
Oh
Nice little he boomi likes to jump up and do a little twirl. Yeah, I get for do a little twirl. Oh good twirl
I think you just hopped down from the counter
I don't know if you guys heard him talking back to me
Somebody miss built taser and type taxer so I could say someone's chasing me with a taxi
Okay, someone just did
What did you like any classroom? Oh that reminds me that the um
They're gonna do the fireworks on the 13th in my area. Oh
Keep an eye. Yeah, they they're not they're not anywhere you miss you
I
What are you doing stop hopping up on the counter
He's like looking for the soup you can't have any
When you do
He's like head butting the air he'll just like jump up on his hind legs and just like head but nothing
Are you gonna hop up here? That's fine. You can't have my soup though
Yeah, it's hot you can tell that it's hot you can't have any milk is a broth is cereal a soup
You
Can't have any of this
Why are you just chewing on random stuff on my desk?
He's head butting my microphone, I apologize
Pop-tarts are ravioli
That is a fact let him cook I think I have a picture
Boomi was just like chilling on the um
Stove and I'm like can somebody tell my cat to get off the stove and also can someone tell my cat to get out of the
Fridge and the dishwasher and the washing machine because he likes to crawl into those things because he's freaking crazy
What are you chewing on?
Oh
What are you eating is that a bug oh my god
What is it don't eat that keep it alone what is this?
It's like a fucking beetle
Boomi is a 24-7 job usually it's Fia but Fia is chilled out
Usually Fia is like always on my desk and stuff, but
He's chilling by the window right now
I
Can't tell if the soup tastes okay or not it's fine
What are you yelling about
Sir
Why are you yelling in my bathroom? Okay, I don't know if you guys heard me go
Hi, I see
Hello Raiders. Hello Snow Berries. Hello Dada's
I'm eating some soup before I start and we're just chatting and hanging out
Hi, I'm she be caught mom your favorite girl failure nom whip boo whip boo. I don't know yippie
I'm having some chicken old soup and trying to fight off my cat
Because I turned around and he was eating the soup from the pot when I was sitting at my desk
I
See gets it she has a son
She has potato and was it backlash backlash. Voila. I should pronounce it
Snow bunnies
If you're a fan of me and I see your snow bunny
Yeah, what can I?
Balhash
No, not baklava
I hope you had a good stream. I saw that in me in me. I see was playing brats
This is what happens when you give everybody the first letter of the name and then the last letter of the name the exactly same
Sipping sipping on my my seltzer water my ginger lime a seltzer water
and um
Yeah, straw knee she be I see in me. Yeah, I know other people do that. Like I've been called straw knee before
um
Yeah, guys you're playing brats
brats
I remember I used to have like a little mini disc of like the brats angels that came with one of my brats dolls when I had a
brats doll
I think I had chloe and um
There's brats angels or brats forever. I can't remember rock angels. Yeah
I'm her listening to the song. I have to burp. I need to mute
Hi bleep my so wait, no
It'll work. I don't know if it worked
Oh my crap, did I like not bleep it?
Yeah, you get you get bleeped burps. Nobody deserves my burps
The bleep was bleeping she's such a criminal
When I was in the third grade they called me a criminal why because I killed somebody
Start rating bleeps I could do morse code not that I know morse code, but I could figure it out
I
Choked on a noodle
I can see that behind a fit area. What do you mean? Of course mercy. She's literally the Andre
Did I burp I don't remember burping if I did I'm sorry
I
Nice belts bro anytime bro, huh bro fist, but I just like to shove my fist up your butt
affectionately
Yeah, but the undead I already had three what
On an arena stream became a lunch ASMR. I've already told you guys I like to eat with you guys
One because you guys encourage me to eat and I don't like eating alone
See without you I wouldn't have remembered that I have chicken noodle soup Campbell's chicken noodle soup in my cabinet
And I would have probably just kept eating applesauce
Thanks for the fist bro anytime bro
That's literally called a mukbang that's true
Mukbang except I'm not like shoving like an absurd amount of cheese down my throat. I'm just eating Campbell's chicken noodle soup
Yeah, then you wouldn't have the lovely clip that someone probably took of boomi taking my soup
I don't know what the cheese is but well, there's a lot of like cheese pulls and stuff and mukbangs
I couldn't watch mukbangs because then I would want to eat what the people were eating
But like obviously on a smaller scale
So like anytime I watch like a sushi or like a fish related mukbang
I would have to get like sushi
And I'm like this is hurting my wallet
Campbell's sponsor stream
If I could get any sponsor, you know, I'm who my dream sponsor is guess who I want you to guess who my dream sponsor is right now
Let me switch to a gaming
Tampax
Why are people saying tampa why'd you say it twice you get that'd be pretty cool. Um, no
It's smuckers uncrustables
That is my dream
Strawny is my dream sponsor that too
If I could get smuckers uncrustables
Then that would be incredible. I don't know why there's not game sound
Let me figure that out expeditiously and put my headphones in
I want to make a PB and J because it's the novelty bro. It's the novelty
Okay
Imagine me on an uncrustable and I'm just like just hanging out, you know, let me put my ooo mouth on
Why can I only hear
Everything besides the game
Da da da da da da
Um Elden ring where for oh
Is that it? Yeah
Yeah
Okay, I can hear it but now you guys can't
Unless you guys can hear it. I don't know if you can
Devoured okay, cool. Um properties
Is
Nope
It will probably randomly be under music because I don't know why but it puts
Game audio under music on my go xlr. I should probably fix that
Come on play again
Hold on hold on. Hold on. I've got this. I like how I do one thing in it. Why is my mic peaking?
What happened? What happened to my settings from my last collab?
Oh
You heard your first second
Oh, there it is. I might turn that motherfucker down. Holy crap. Sorry
Sorry that game audio is gone now for a second because I need to do something in
YouTube studio. So I'm not so bright
Um, what the shibbity? Where is it? Here it is
There it is
I should have taken a picture of my go xlr settings before they got yuffed up
Cause that's poopy. That's real poopy. That's what I'm gonna say
Is that better? Sure. Okay
Uh
Oh scared me
I'm a star
I guess we actually have to play a game. I'm still sipping. I'm still sipping my poop. Hello. Hi. We started early today
Oh, they don't like about camel chicken noodle soup is that it's so salty
It's too salty for me. How am I supposed to swallow this?
Mmm
You'll show me what? What do you mean? I didn't say anything bad
I
Water it down. Yeah, I think I've done that before
I see
Don't ice cube in there. Well, it's it's already gone. I actually finished it
Which I'm surprised because again, like I said, I've been like very nauseous because of my bed, so
Don't worry, you'll probably fall asleep and I'll be streaming eight hours from now. So
Don't worry about it. You won't miss anything
Crack my back
Time to stretch
Oh
I'm so close to popping it and I can't
Just works
She'll be having eight hours from now after playing the game for three hours
Shit, but my favorite underground indie artist
You best you bested mogul last night. He's the first boss to give you a hard time cool
So you're gonna help me defeat him, right?
Just kidding. I'll I'll fight him
What did you guys say you guys wanted me to fight morgot too and uh
God-free
Okay
Cozy I'm here. I'm ready to rumble. I got my pillow pet mr. Quackerton as my little armrest
Need to adjust I need to bleep
I
Forgot and I can just be you I don't have to bleep it
No burpees for you
Yeah, god-free another talisman pouch
Uh, I also probably should get some memory stones for spells
Because I was doing a lot of oh my god. I need to turn out the game for me
That didn't work at all
There we go turns it down for me and not for you that actually works out. Um
Are you changing our normal burps because I feel I feel like I've been giving you guys too much
And it's time for me to withhold things
You didn't you didn't do anything. I just want to torture you so no burps for you. Um
Um, what was I gonna say?
Oh, so I was doing some research on like best
Things to do. I really watched an hour video about the top 75 best sorceries
And I'm like, okay, do I run around and grab those and I'm like, I don't think I will. Um, but
Going in to I like to do research. Okay for Elden Ring. It's fun
I like to listen to Elden Ring stuff. Um
Going into a mug is going to be difficult
One because my build he's pretty resistant to
So
Yeah, that'll be something unless I get like, uh the comment
I could probably get that
um
Maybe mugged mowed
Uh could also maybe get some frost stuff
I wish I had the video up because it has like a lot of good information about
um
The scaling and stuff for
the sorceries
erm
Let me see
I have to get a different weapon besides the moon veil
to fight
Mogue with because he is resistant to magic
I think like a little bit, but he's I think I'm gonna get
the
Either the the no the either the uji katana or the naga kaiba nakiba naga kiba
I can't remember the name and then do get a poison ash of war for that
um
Because I don't feel like although, I don't know. Do I need higher dexterity for that? I probably do
Brick yeah, he is weak to bleed however
He is he is like 20 magic resisted. I watched a video leave me alone
um
He's like resistant to everything
Yes, he's heavily fit obviously like he is fire resistant, but for best
Build
Yeah, he's 80 percent fire percent
20% oh, okay. I thought it was 40 percent. I can't remember whatever. All right, then we should be fine then with the moon veil
So I don't have to do that
uh, we still have to
go
and
Go to the sofra
I can't pronounce it correct me because I would like to know. I know it's like irish. Um
River well to get the mimic tear
So like oh, I guess so much enough to do
You
Um, then I have to go
Get more got I don't remember why
I have to level the mimic tear. That's also true
So I'm sorry. No, I haven't seofra. Okay. See. I was right seofra. Um
What else gotta get god-free get god
What should we do first?
I remember where I am. I remember what I was doing last or was I?
Oh lovely fire column
God-free
For memory stones. Oh my thing isn't plugged in because she's not plugged in
Mict here
But I don't even have the third talisman slot. Where do I get the third talisman slot from I only have two slots
I forget
Okay, so that okay, so we'll go to
Oh, yeah, now I remember what I was doing. I was getting this the sacred tears
Um
I was getting the sacred tears
Market yeah, not margot. I don't know I'm talking I'm talking about market
uh
Talk to the finger lead around table if you're going to be going to the third. Oh, that's right. Okay. I gotta go talk to her
I'll go talk to her for that. I should probably get better talismans
Um, I'm gonna keep focusing on what I was doing which was doing the sacred tears
Um, I have I have to pull it up
I have to pull it up
Frick
Iron
Let me do that
Sacred tears locations. I also need to get better physics
Okay, I'm at bellen church. Oh, yeah, I need to go to the church of inhibition next
That's what I was looking at. I'm gonna make you guys another
Please do next
I need to make a checklist. You're right. I really do though
Um, where the church of inhibition is in learnea. Oh my god. I fucking hate this
Um, no, that's not what I wanted to do. Oh wait, maybe I should use I'll use my controller instead of fuck
Instead of my mouse. Um, so the church of inhibition
Is over there. I already marked it because I was like, yeah, that's where we're going. All right
Wait, is it number four? What did I mark it as?
This is four, okay
I'm only like level like a hunt like like 45. Oh, you have a bonus. Come here. Wait. No, not you
Can I?
Thank you
Checklists as I know I have like I'm trying to keep remember everything in my head. Um, how do I get up there?
I'll run past you guys
church of inhibition
I took forever for them to walk on me though
This is the plateau, isn't it to get to the thingy? Then I gotta go up here, right?
Oh fuck, why is it I forget how to get up there and I can't look on my map
I remember trying to figure out how to find these stuff before
Uh
It's a little it's a little crystal bud. Okay, then I go this way
To
But how
Hmm
Oh
There it is
Get to the church
Oh, no, I forgot the fucking eyes around. Oh, no, I can't look at it
Oh, where the fuck oh fuck
I'm fine. I'm fine. Don't worry about it
Not looking at it not looking at it
We are not looking at it
We're not looking at it
It's fine
Hi to from it. No, it killed me god damn it
I hate that it does that I'm like I wish it was like when I'm looking at it it would
Sorry keep as it can't keep his eye off of me. You're right. Great. Now. I gotta go fucking do that again
All right, Lisa now know where I'm going
Hello sheepies
Hello wolfies like how they're just chillin
La la la
We serpentine
Oh, no
Why did I not get hit before and now I'm gonna get hit. No
Uh torrent come back, please torrent torrent. I'm begging you
I'm cool. I'm cool. Leave me alone
Yeah, I know that but I don't care about the tower
It's called yeah, it's runaway simulator. That's what I'm playing
All right
It's like if I hide behind a rock, it's fine
Although it immediately will pop up immediately when I get closer
Let's see if I'm behind the fucking that's why these rocks are here. Fuck off. You stupid fucking rat
Then I gotta just wait for it to disappear
Go away don't look at me like that you fucking mouse
All right go
I'm stuck on a fucking tree. No god damn it
I'm gonna be madness. Oh, I died shit
Oh, okay, it looks like we have to clear this fucking castle
Cool enough
Yeah, I'm debating whether or not if I should have gone the other way
Okay
Incorrect
All right attempt number
Three third time's a charm. Am I right am I right? I'm just gonna go this way
So you don't get hit by rocks
maybe
Uh, I don't know they seem to not aggro until I come a lot closer
I'm coming closer
They have not found me yet
For shit for fuck
Oh, you didn't get me. Ha ha ha. I'm too fast for you. I am too fast
And you cannot turn around the trebuchets to hit me you motherfuckers
All right, I'm going to fuck this castle up
Herm
Oh
Get down get down
Coming at me
Get over here. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Oh
Is there another mouse nearby? What am I hearing? Oh, it's just rolling down the hill slowly
The eye of sauron watches over us all
It's really gone for only like a split fucking second though
Let's I get right under it's like right here. Oh
I'm gonna let that go down
Another shivy voice for the collection my my really bad french accent
Now I to hug the wall
Because this is a son of a beach
I just knew what this is. What is that? I want to pick it up. I want to pick it up
I
Don't see let me pick it up. There we go. It's a bird a bolt whatever the fuck that means
Okay
What is causing this commotion? How oh i'm going to die
I'm going to die
I'm going to get madness. I'm going to die
I'm going to run away. My cat food is going off
I'm close to death
Oh
I'm going to die to mice. I'm going to die the mice. I'm going to die the madness. I'm going to die the mice in madness
Men of mice, what's that book madness of men mice of men
The frenchy impression
It didn't sound like frenchy
I
Myself man
I'm on you now. We have to jump over this little hole
You will continue on
I cannot
If I go up higher it sounds more seductive
Hello, my name is uh, el iris
I'm from paris
I heard you like to draw the french girls
I am one
Katerynaic
Do you like my my commentary?
Mankur
Which means like my sister or something or my cousin I can't remember
The food dispenser like jumpscared, do you know what the fault is?
It's another reason why I kind of choked there
I didn't realize what time it oh, yeah, it's three
three
Fuck this flaming pile of shit get off the horse hug the side
Oh crouch
Fuck
Irm
No, why can't I I'm trying to hide from it. It's not working
I'm
Being
Dotten by madness
Oh, fuck. Oh, shit. Oh quick heel heel
I'm tired of this I'm tired of this grandpa
I'm tired. I just want to go up to get the sacred tear and it's so difficult for me. I don't know why
I need a nap. Am I already eat me? It's raining
Okay
We're zooming
So
Cooler his heart. Oh, yeah, I don't I don't I took four years of friends. Do you think I remember any of that shit? I don't
Fuck off bug
Hey, what's up? Good to see everybody gotta go wish I could say I gotta go fight the eye of sauron real quick
I'll be right back
I
Still have to watch the most recent boys episode. I just remembered
Okay, uh, let's go. Okay, there is like a limit to
I
Crouch
I'll be the fucking mice don't see me
I had behind a tree
Oh, there's a second one. Oh
Hey, do we do we do it abba dabbadi we're walking up this
The ending of it was nice to fly as practice. What episode are we on?
There we go
Like how like torrent doesn't go mad or anything imagine if torrent could go mad
Safe in here, right?
I'm trying to walk on to this instead
I
Coolio
Fuck this stupid thing I'm out and I thought I was climbing with him
It was not I like how although I'm right under it. It doesn't affect me it always confused me
What's your foolish ambitions to rest
Stop it
Enough
Oh, it's still there. Oh, I'm gonna die. Oh, I pressed the wrong button. I feel the wrong thing
I
One of the acolytes fell god damn it fuck that acolyte
Gosh darn
God damn it scoop
I know I saw one of them fall. I'm like, oh, hopefully they'll die. It's just they did not
Oh to be a wolf with your little pack
I
I saw them fall off and I was like, where are they going? No
It's pretty not smart to have like a statue in the middle of a road
His faith was stronger than your backstab literally
Hey do be do be do is I mean like all of them are respawned because I didn't kill that one
Gonna commit
I
Probably is the case
Oh, I'm gonna get madness. Fuck
Oh, fuck these fucking rats though. Oh my god, I'm so pissed
I don't know. Why am I doing this? Why am I doing? I want the sacred tear. It's stupid though
This shouldn't be taking me so long. I'm really pissed at myself right now
Do I need to lock in do I need to know if I lock in I'm just gonna make a fool of myself
Shouldn't the shouldn't the rain be putting the flames out I still I'm gonna say
Let's don't talk about today's death counter. Don't worry about it
Crawling in my skin
These moves they will not hear
Fuck off
No, wait, I'm sorry. I wanted to look around but I don't know how to control camera properly near that tower is a grace
I know it's like right near it I just
I
Am I going I'm fucking stupid. I'm not paying attention because I'm looking at chat
Hey, nice to see you again big stony guy. Um, can you guys like not do that?
That'd be great. Oh my god. Thank you. I should I didn't have to hop up on torrent
Oh, ha ha you missed
You son of a bitch
He's fucking rats. Yeah, okay. I'm gonna wait till it goes again
What a sight and then now
Wow
Can I please
All right, where's the fucking grace point the way chat
Assuming it's down here
Fuck
I get it site because it's an eye
The sun's coming out. I don't see any clouds
I'm hiding behind a tree so I can't see me
It's over the over where
I'm not gonna make that
Uh, what if I like hug the side?
Oh, wait, I think I should be good
Fuck no, I'm not good. No, I'm not good. I'm not good. Wait. I'm good. I'm fine. Everything's fine
Yeah, what up?
Where where where the gray sat horse
Sorry scratching my ear. I like how there's like a church over here
And um
And it's all like
How's the new build dungeon? Let me not jump off. Let me not kill myself. Okay about that
I
Will slay those motherfuckers
Sorry, I'm not much help. You're fine
This fucking dude over here trying to look trying to look hard
Hey, yo, this is not the right place
I am not in the right place
It's over there. I'm so fucking stupid. I'm like, this isn't right
This isn't this isn't correct
I'm gonna solve the puzzle
What puzzle?
Across the village, ma'am
This fit is hard his fit does go hard. I will say his fit does go hard
Any puzzle solvers in chat because I am not one
Um, yeah, it's over there
Where's the fucking eye
Is it gonna hurt me from this distance? It will not. Oh now it will look behind the tree
It he does match my fit a lot we're like wearing the same outfit. It's like we both showed up
And we accidentally were like matching and it was really awkward
I need a glen stone crown of the gesture erudition interesting
I don't think I ever completed that when I play my play through
Yeah
I'm behind a rock. What are you telling me?
Oh being attacked by a rat. Oh the fucking rat. I need a heal. Oh, not the wolf. Oh god wolf. Why you betrayed me?
I thought you were my pack member
The fuck is this grace guys? I'm looking it up. Where the fuck is the grace?
It's pissing me off. This is gonna be a lot more simpler and I'm just
On your left
That's the little in the outskirts of the fucking village
Alrighty, all right, where'd the fucking chat go? Hello chat
Chat is as real there you guys are I didn't assert dominance and like the wolf
Hi, hi
All right, uh
Why am I stuck on a fucking tree? Um
This is for what you're fucking
I did what I must
Anyways
The copypasta was hot. It's funny
Why are you yawning so much don't get hit by a motherfucking rock don't get hit by a motherfucking rock
Run right passes motherfucking guy run right past these motherfucking guys run away run away
We're running away out running away. Don't know how the fuck he hit me. He never did that mark before
He's still fucking following me Jesus Christ
Usually you fucking diagro by now what the hell's wrong with you
What the hell is wrong with you calling pita do it
I'm gonna call pita on you for wanting to f a rabbit. How about that? Huh? Yeah, how about that? How does that make you feel?
Fuck this off. I hate that you're stuck on rocks
If you're lucky, I'm getting off my horse for this
Stop fucking up my points. Jesus die already
Why am I why is my lock just like not working out for me today?
I
What this I didn't grab it. It's fine
What why was there a health bar for some reason all right, it's over here
I'm gonna hide behind this fucking tree hide behind just hug these fucking walls
Cause this is pacing me off
Erm
Where is it?
It's on the outskirts of the fucking where is it hand over the fucking grace you motherfuckers. Where is it?
What are you guys doing here? You guys don't look like friends. Oh, you are frenzy flame shoulders awkward
Erm
I'm being followed being followed by a fucking rat
It's up there where I am
Wrong area. Where is the church? The church is over here. Okay. I'm facing the right way
All right, we'll keep going
Oh
Fuck is this do a guy doing hey, sorry, I can't talk to you when I'm on horseback
Um
What it am I about to enter a boss battle? What's happened? Oh my fucking god
I hate it here. Oh joy. It's fucking bike I ever got
I
Like where the fuck are you at? Oh, I'm gonna fight in this bushes. No
There he is
I'm gonna die
I couldn't heal
The grace is before you guys aren't helpful. I'm looking up a video
I
Can't run past bike because then the fucking thing will get me and I can't do it on when I'm not on torrent
Is this in Korean
What
You
Yeah, that's what I'm looking at right now is the interact interactive map because you guys suck
There's one right there
Literally right here
You
No, you can't even suck pussy properly you guys just guys just blow you suck and you blow I like that
That's what we didn't do
I
Ask one simple question you guys could describe it on the map
You're just going saying go left and yes while the delay is minimal. There's still a delay
I'll probably already have run 10 fucking feet in the wrong direction by the time you guys say anything
Yeah, go that way I'm like what way I'm pointing this way I was pointing this way
It's just so funny to me. I haven't played the game. Yes, you've already said that you haven't played the game
I said I was by the rocks by the tower the rock there's so many rocks by the fucking tower
What the fuck are you talking about bro? Are you kidding me?
I'm never asking you guys for anything again
Are
That take forever to cast
Yeah, madam is gonna beat you. How about that?
All right, where was
They mark it it is two. Okay
It is straight ahead essentially
There's
Oh, thank god
Oh
Whopper bottoms, and yeah, not in the nice way. Oh, I didn't mean to press up
Cool
I can be in okay, then you just get scolded and not even degraded just like just told how
Unhelpful you are
This madness
This is sparta. I'm gonna get attacked by mice in a second. I'm
Oh, that's fine. I didn't mean to click that one
I'm not madness I'm disappointedness. Mm-hmm
It's over why am I here? Oh
I thought I fucking appeared
in the same fucking
Spot as I did before I was getting really pissed
Come on it should have the time one should have been off
I'm just gonna die again. Oh
There's a spirit spring those
What
Right before the gap in the rocks before this grace there is a spirit spring
Do you mean like the little teleporter shit?
What the fuck are you on what gap?
You
Making my way down turn up. Where am I going going to the fucking earth tree not earth tree minor earth tree
Torrent bounce pad through
Yeah, I saw there is like a little there's a little gap over here
Wow my eyes my eyes. Why is this thing have so much fucking reach?
How am I supposed to use that to get all the way over there though? Because that's still a lot
Before I even get up here
Get up here. You know it was easier when I came out from this angle to be honest with you
When I was hanging out with my homeboy with a nice fit
It's fine
It's fine. I'm good just gotta
Run and hide behind this rock
The easiest rod up is from the Texas
You
What why don't you die there?
Any more you come at me bro
I don't think any of you I was there
I'm so determined to kill his eye out of just pure. Oh what the fuck is a mouse
It's fine. Get the fucking mouse
Where am I?
Where am I? Oh, there it is
Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me
Excuse me ow. Excuse me ow
Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me. I just wanted to see if I could just run up the ladder
She's just calling this boy. So it is really crowded in there. It fell claustrophobic
I guess I wasn't excused. Yeah
What the fuck it is wouldn't let me call torn for a second. It looks so confused
Uh
Run
That's a fucking rat
Ow
Why can't I hit any of you make that make any fucking sense
I don't get why am I not like I just get why are these fucking rats stunlocking me
I don't get it. Why am I being stunlocked by the rats?
I don't understand
Maybe it's because I'm level 45 and I'm here
Where am I going?
Where am I supposed to be go? I don't remember. I just got turned around. Where am I?
Fuck this fucking eye. I am destroying it. I don't even care about what I was doing before
I'm going to be doing this for the next five hours. Yes, you are correct
I wouldn't want it any other way
I
I'm I'm I'm getting molested. Please help
Anyways on foot. Oh, what the fuck fuck off you motherfuckers
Well, you want some you want some come on come on then eat that
Why that takes so long it's another one right here come on bitch get aggroed
Get aggroed over here
She being the hood kind of scary what
What the fuck am I doing what's up with my camera, bro
All right, we're just gonna whoop and then we're gonna climb
It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fucking fine
Oh
Ha you motherfucking rats can't climb you sons of bitches
Again I still don't understand how this doesn't affect me but go off. Oh, what's that? I didn't see this before
I got the howl of Shibibibibi Shabibibi Shibbubi Shabubi
I'm gonna die fast. Oh, wow madness. This is sparta
Stop it enough
Thank you very much
Anyways, I swear to god these rats kill me, I'm actually gonna permit, let me see if
I can, eeeeh, nice, anyways, hi, I killed your mom, I'm gonna kill you next, enough!
I said stop!
Alright, um, so, to the church of inhibition, haha!
Yeah, where am I going?
Towards four, where's four? Over here, out, I just got a pain in my arm.
Oh, got a 1v1 with vike, that'll be nice, it'll be fun with us, where am I going?
Hey, I always get so lost in fucking from soft games, um,
oh I have to go, I have to go through there first, alright!
Hug the wall, why would I hug the wall, I don't need to hug the wall.
How about my strap hugs your walls, yeah, anyways, who was that?
I want it, I want it, give it to me! Oh fuck, uh, hold on, please,
I guess it's not worth it, so I'll just keep going.
That was fun, that was a fun little excursion, uh, just got jumped, I gotta fight this motherfucker,
or you know, bad to you too, brother, I respect you for that, I'm just gonna spam,
what am I doing, I'm just gonna talk to this guy.
Yes, vike my darling, where for out the vike?
No, nothing, alright, oh there we go.
Oh fuck, um, uh, you know what, I'm actually just gonna run away from you,
because I am too underleveled, wow.
No, I can't touch the grace, oh fuck you vike,
oh, wow, I need that anyways, I need that for Vari's quest,
where is he, oh fuck, yes do that, do that, please just let me touch it,
yes,
is it, no,
fine, I got what I wanted,
got him, yeah, I know I would need that grace,
um, I'm just too underleveled, I'm only level like, what level am I, I think I'm level like 45,
what am I doing,
well 53,
hi lady, you don't look so good, whoa, why can't I see through this pillar, that's
kind of weird, why is it doing that, what,
I got to walk in,
this is OP against NPCs, I know I keep forgetting to use my ash of war on this,
alright let's try it, vike, where you at,
vike,
walk in, he, he, he, fuck, can I roll out the way, he, fuck, can I back up,
he, why isn't working, why did it go that way, I, I, I hate this here, I hate it here, no,
why,
you're so, you're do so good, why are you lying to me, why are you lying to me, don't lie to me,
stop,
no I just want to, I already got the grace I needed, but you already got the grace,
you're too, you're, you're late bro, you're late, I already got the grace, I just want to try to kill him,
it's like my, my lock is just like not working,
can you, enough,
she blinded me with madness, she blinded me with madness, I'm too underleveled for that,
he just walks away, he's like yeah, bye bitch,
you just get cooked a little bit, we can get it back,
okay, all right, all right, all right, all right, okay, so we got what we needed there,
what was the other, I was looking for the secret,
he made a secret and left, okay, the restaurant, there's a church of the plague in Kailu that has it,
and there's someone the Altus Plateau, but I won't really do that yet, because Altus
Plateau is not really my priority right now, where the fuck is this,
it's like right in a crooked road, no I'm not fucking, hit, here,
making my way downtown,
like I'm looking at a puzzle piece, where is this, is it right over here,
walking fast, faces passing homebound,
that probably was not the best grace to go to, what are we working towards again,
I'm getting all the sacred tears, not all of them, just like a good chunk,
I should probably look for some golden seeds while I'm at it, I should probably do that too,
I have so many fucking tags, let me back up, so that one's three,
I wish there was a way to just clear all my beacons,
is that a thing, is there a toggle to do that, I highly doubt it, get rid of you,
no, I just wanted to, thank you,
no not those kind of tags, you fucking idiots,
all right, where's one, where's this one pointing at, one is,
what the hell,
there's a one, what is one,
sorry I like have to fix that because it's gonna bother me, so I usually follow the track,
till I find it,
where the fuck is one,
how do I remove all, I'm gonna keep yelling at you unless you tell me,
oh there it is, I found it,
I want some ice cream, I would love some ice cream actually, I have an ice cream in like a very long
time, great, time to figure out how to get the fuck down up, you know what, are you serious,
that's so fucking stupid in it,
anyways,
you're telling me that that hurts me, that is the dumbest shit I've ever seen,
oh yeah, cry, cry, cry, I was about to say if I fucking die from this I'm gonna actually fight
um, Kaelin, wow, did not know I was here, um, oh fuck, oh I'm fine,
anyways,
what is rising behind me, skeleton boys,
alright, let me just run over this and there's one in here, oh these motherfuckers, yeah no,
we're not doing that today, oh hey, it's you, um, I'm sorry but I'm not interested into what you
have to sell, oh come on bro, I don't, I don't have time for this, just leave me, you fucking house
centipedes, I hate those, why are you so fast for no reason, are you good bro, oh fuck, I'm like
literally about to die, you get crushed like a bug, alright,
yeah why don't you hug him with your little doofy ass hats, um, you don't look too good,
she's probably fine right,
handing out ice cream in the chat, you have to save her, she's hot, I don't feel like doing her quest,
she's like breathing so heavily in my fucking ears,
um, alright, let's look for golden seeds,
okay, uh, frick, damn, there's so many, oh,
so long inflation,
for this fucking ad, I'll put you guys right next to the article,
long disease ASMR, okay, I'm in Kaleid right now, there's one in the B-seal sect, um,
heading to the B-seal sect, where the fuck is that, where's the, I mean,
map link,
oh I think I already grabbed that, yeah I did, okay,
there's one in the cellio town of sorcery under a phantom tree in the northern section of town,
okay, let's go talk to invisible people, we love to see you, yeah,
can you travel to that ship, no, that'd be cool if you could, I don't know, can you travel to
that ship, I don't know, I've never been able to, um, what is happening, what is, what is happening,
what's happening, what is happening to my stick, why isn't it moving,
the fuck, that was a weird ass glitch, anyways, um, I'm right next to the cellio town of sorcery,
it's like right over here, it's like, like up here, here, all right, let's go talk to these bitches,
damn it, oh I see it, oh there's a way for me to get down, nice,
nice, something behind me,
oh
comical typing,
oh thank god there's a grace right here,
I'm so close to death, no, I meant to sit down, Jesus Christ, don't you hate when just like balls
just like go to your face, just sucks, um, okay, this is the tree, it was like literally over there,
oh
are you shitting me right now, what do you have to say about this,
oh it's because I went the back way,
damn I have to go around,
I hear people creepily making noises on the other side, oh it's that,
oh, um, I'm fine,
yeah I'm fine,
nice, uh cool, I totally just,
cool, yeah, nice, cool,
what a beautiful town, really, look how, how gorgeous it is, it's so empty,
can't believe nobody lives in this gorgeous, beautiful town, I kind of want to drop down on this
thing, yeah,
yeah, uh, oh quick teleport,
I don't want to accidentally aggro people when I can't get out,
I got a bullet, I'm scared, I'm so sorry,
you live there, I'm so sorry that you do, um, okay, cool, we got that,
uh,
one can be, did I get that one near red main,
I mean I think I did, I think, did I,
I'm sorry, I wanted to do these ones, um, oh yeah, no I definitely talked to him,
um, so I definitely probably grabbed that one, question mark, let me just sit down,
I need three golden seeds,
uh, I think I already grabbed that one, am I winning, that's debatable,
there's also the pewter tree spirit, but I don't feel like doing that, um,
okay, let's go to limb grave, because I haven't, I haven't gone to limb grave,
I also haven't gone to fort height,
yeah, there's fort height, there's the starfall center, uh,
fort height is over here, it is,
it was really interesting, my first playthrough,
um, I had a weird glitch that live never spawned,
and I didn't do anything, like it's like I literally was like playing the game
as linearly as it can get, and you could hear Blythe like howl and shit or whatever the
fuck noise he makes, but then I never saw him, he never, and he's like, you know he's like at
the top of that thing or whatever, I had to restart my game so I could talk to him,
I didn't, well I just made another game, I just, because I was just like, what the fuck, it was
really weird, uh, yeah the whistle never worked, yeah because you have to get the whistle so he
shows up, yeah it never worked, he just glitched and never showed, hi, I don't feel like talking to you,
um, not that I have any money to buy shit,
hey, how's it going,
how's it going everyone, I don't mind if I grab that real quick, oh I gotta go,
it's been cool, nice seeing you all, it's been a really long time,
glad to see you guys are all in good spirits, love that for you,
yeah, oh yeah there's just a thingy, um, I still, okay I'm not, uh, where is the other one,
yeah I was really annoying,
let me find the sleeping peninsula,
fuck, did I get that one, I can't recall,
I don't think I did, again I've literally just been bouncing around places so I probably haven't
gone to places, oh, okay maybe I did, we'll just see,
so literally like right here, let's see if I
got that one because I can't recall if I did,
isn't there like a giant here,
yeah, there it is, I don't think I grabbed it because of the giant,
um, yeah there it is,
I think I was more distracted by the giant, yep,
let her go towards, good job, make it down, thank you,
that's a close one, yikes, um, so aggro, I can't get out of here,
yippee, let me just get rid of that marker, I can't get rid of the marker, let's just float,
run at the marker,
whoa, we're gonna kill this giant,
get him, hurry before he shoots the ground,
yeah,
ow,
yeah, what, I thought I jumped, I'm just not jumping, at least you're not doing that much
damage to me, that's cool, um, thanks, I'm sure you can have your bow, that'd be nice, arm,
arm, what's up here again, how are we gonna,
aw, thank you,
your sheepee tax, that's cute, thank you, thank you for the tip,
um, when you guys are useless, just start paying me money, that's sad,
okay, I got that, wait, why don't I, I just forget to do things,
tutorial island, that's a good way of putting it,
cool, nice, okay, so we got the riot,
um,
if I kill Kenneth height, I can get one,
I didn't know I could kill Kenneth height for a fucking thing,
so,
if you kill him, he gives you a golden seed,
Kenneth did nothing wrong, you can max it out without killing him, I never knew that,
because I completed his quest before, and I know I could kill him, I just would have,
learning of the gains,
damn, there's one in the carry a manor, I do love carry a manor, it's one of my favorite levels
to clear, there's one in oxtella, there's one in sofra, lindel, yeah, two can be found
underneath the phantom tree inside the western gate, capillel skirts,
he's gonna steal her to stormville castle when you steal her elven line,
I think completing this quest along with the water, yeah, nepheli, whatever,
you max upgrade, yeah, I did that before, okay, there's really nothing else I could grab
without having to defeat bosses, because there's also a tree spirit in the pharynx roll
heroes grave, and I do have the key to get into that, and there's also the putrid spirit boss
at the end of the war dead catacombs, so that would be two, but that's not really my goal right
now, my goal is just because I would rather be leveled so I can just fuck everybody up
and then get those later, so now
I'm thinking we go get that mimic tear, I think, I think it's time
the base talisman, what's the base talisman,
I did clear the pharynx roll heroes grave, I just don't remember the name of shit,
I just don't remember the name of shit,
where's the lady with the fingers, where's the finger lady, I'm gonna finger her so fucking hard,
what does the earth treats favor do, I forget, hey
you think I'm cute, you have some interesting toes
I hate them so much, they're so fucking gross okay,
just some random eldritch, they're not even like part of something,
they're not like part of a big hand, or they are part of a big hand, and the hand talks to her,
and it's because of the outer lords, where's your head, oh yeah I don't care,
thank you,
big preach, big preach, uh
what am I doing, you have incantations but I'm not doing that,
oh the all knowing, the all glowing, I'm gonna destroy your entire fucking area,
oh you can't destroy as much as you could, I remember you could destroy literally everything in
this room, and now you can't, where is he, where the fuck is this bitch, and what do I have to do,
I'm hoping it isn't mine, I did some redecorating,
this looks pretty good,
yeah I remember before you could like fucking destroy this table, I mean destroying literature,
I thought the emissary of the greater well are two fingers sitting in a room, yeah I just,
honestly George R. R. Martin, and was it Miyazaki, yeah I'm fucking stupid, they're interesting,
did I, I already unlocked the dung eater,
hey
I never finished your quest, you're fucking weird though, you just like
fucking desecrate people's corpses, um
no, here you go,
oh nifty, nice bell bearing bitch,
this bitch is just festering bloody finger,
because it's like night armor, night helm,
they don't, let me buy that,
I'm like guano goblin, caca consumer,
ever felt the curse, no,
like kindly let me go talk to the lady so I can get
this dude's bow,
again I always get turned around to this place, these ugly ass fingers, why is it two weird fingers,
I don't, who's supposed to sit here, that's not you,
I would like to receive equipment of champions, I don't have enough money,
sorry, I need to receive power,
thank you, big preach,
I thought she was gonna tell me to go fuck myself,
see uh, I have a good time at work, I'll see you in eight hours,
I should do anything with those games, I could tell what's happening, don't worry about it,
the two fingers and three fingers make a hand, why, I don't know,
yeah because Ronnie likes the three fingers, they like the two fingers and they together make a hand,
because you got like the thumb is supposed to definitely be over here and then you,
I feel like this is, yeah the thumb's supposed to be over here, then the ring and the pinky finger
and then those are the three fingers, they're so gross, I hate them so much, um Ronnie likes the three fingers,
wait I forget, who likes the three fingers, yeah Ronnie doesn't want any, she's like I
fucking hate the greater will, I need to watch like another one of those lore videos with the
update stuff with the DLC, hey it's you, I used to think this guy was cute, why, I don't know
because you can't even see his fucking face, um yeah it's D, I just think of the fucking memes from
look up, just look up uh Game Grumps playing Elden Ring and they do the funniest fucking
little bit for D and it's hilarious, they already killed the Mariners,
over all the Rika, how are you doing,
yes you have a gift,
yeah that's crazy,
okay bye, oh where's Master Hugue, it's not over there, get fucking dizzy walking around this
fucking room, oh hey what the fuck are you doing,
yeah it's me, yeah I don't, I don't think you're doing your job, um I don't,
do I have a sombersmithing's job, I can't tell that's telling me that I do or if I don't have one,
I just don't have enough money,
four hundo,
oh hundo, I don't, oh well it's too late, hi,
where's the fourth, where's the somber stone, where is that,
I know I forget, I forget if it's what's on the outside or what's on the inside,
where's the fourth somber stone,
oh wait I can just, yeah I can just go to EG, that's right, all right I'll just do that,
I don't fucking feel like looking for shit, looks like he's like pounding my ass,
awkward, anyways, whoa, zoom in, zoom in, zoom in, bye,
I'll see you, soon, where, EG, oh again I get turned around, hi how much are your,
how much are your wares,
I need 6,000 runes, that's crazy, I don't have that, is there any way
that you would do something for a little gal, little gal like me,
twitty please,
I don't have any runes I can pop, sorry I didn't mean to say anything, I'm not here, I'm not here,
no, I always forget to do use selected number, is there, no, no I'm not, I'm not doing that
with the giant, price is a price,
I have a fifth one,
I need to still go to Lirnia's tower,
did I do that, actually I can't remember, I don't fucking need that,
can I sell stuff,
would you like, I'll trade you an Aeonian butterfly for that rock,
let me,
fuck, okay well this might not work out,
because I'd rather, I need to level up my weapon before I go to the well,
just so I don't have to worry about it later,
can I sell himself, I can't recall,
no,
let me just go and sell some stuff real quick,
I'll be right back, is this, yeah let's go talk to Kale,
I go Kale is the only one for a name, yeah butterfly for a rock, that's pretty good trade,
you should recommend me a video that has little Hamilton nonstop, nobody knows how to sing,
that's weird,
warranty what, I'm gonna keep that, fuck what can I sell here,
you have terrible prices,
oh yeah yeah I killed giants, okay let's do that, later,
where are the giants,
they are,
what do they like, over here,
let's go to the grafted secluded cell,
where are the giants,
let's go over here,
let's go to the grafted secluded cell,
let's go over here, yeah,
let's do some
shit, Madam Mother Shields and the Thumbnail,
protect you or YouTube, they're here to protect you,
oh I can't use fucking torrent,
why are you telling me how to use a bow,
I don't have a bow equipped, it's irrelevant,
hi, long time no see, hope you're doing well,
waiting for your brother to work up,
yeah, you're stronger than the other one,
are you gonna run,
well I can't precisely,
that's fine, your brothers are beating you up,
I'm kind of just not gonna let that happen,
you guys like hit each other,
I'm gonna let this happen, oh perfect,
can he shoot, shoot,
there we go, is that for me, oh wow, this is crazy, excuse me,
oh you killed him for me, so thanks for that,
nice,
wait don't, don't run away, ow, I forgot you guys fling rocks,
I walked onto you, oh shit, oh what the fuck, oh what the hell,
oh what the hell, let me run away, please,
hi, oh, aren't you naughty, oh, oh, can you come a little closer,
actually, can you like come over here so your boy can shoot you with those arrows,
that'd be great, thank you, can you do that,
can you just hit a pillar, okay that's fine, come over here,
yeah a little bit, come closer,
why don't you come, why don't you run over here, why are you so slow,
any reason, does this affect you, you're made out of rocks, does this do anything,
no not really,
that's nice, I'll stand over here and then I'm gonna run away,
okay, I did it explode, no, you're made, all right, I'll come over here, ow, oh perfect,
that's so nice, oh anyways,
I didn't need a heal for that, please don't shoot at the ground,
damn it, I thought I could jump in time, it didn't work out, okay, really nice to see you,
thank you, appreciate that, you're so kind, drop into your knees for me, as you should,
all right,
that's a lot of damage,
see I'm listening, I'm using my ashes of war guys,
shabriery,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, strength in my arm, wait, hold on, I meant to buy something first,
wait, I bought it but now I don't have enough money, do I have any,
wait, do I, do I,
also recommend me some physics to get before I go to the sofra, I think I also want to do that
next, let me go kill something, how many rooms do I have, I don't know, oh what the fuck Aruni,
I forgot when you get near the carrion manor it does this,
who's casting, I just want to talk,
isn't there a giant troll over here,
why are there so many,
hi, will I be able to leave if I walk in here, okay, I need to kill some hands,
hands,
probably won't matter, oh,
how much damage does he have, can I get up please, no, all right,
yeah I know I need to do that,
what's the one that stops it, it's like blood, crown, shit, I don't fucking know, where's my rooms,
I am not mad at one foot,
how, I feel like, fucks up the targeting, ah, stop,
now,
really just tossed me out of here, oh fuck, can you come out, oh you can, oh shit, oh can I heal,
oh, hold on, oh shit, oh what the hell,
please let me get up, oh god,
is it dead,
hi, I'm gonna throw these rocks at you, you little fucking weird hand spider,
how are you not dead, oh okay, I'm just gonna stay, thank you,
take that, oh, how much is this, 50, those hands are over your hand, I'm trying to get a
feel of madam without permission, that's just creepy as fuck, I will cut them in half, I wouldn't
say they're harem, they're just creepy people because I don't think harem would disrespect me like that,
thank you for the um, the super, yeah harem, harem knows better than the touch of that concern,
the one in northeast lirna gives the magic damage up, okay,
thank you kindly sir,
I don't recall there being red in that helmet, um, bad touchy,
what was I gonna say, what are the names of, you guys need to tell me names of things,
there's a plus 10 intelligence physique down there, down where,
and where, tell me the names of things, they says like if it was lyza p and I told my friend I was
getting older and he laughed at me, say good luck, I love lyza p, lyza p is great, I love lyza p,
you guys are telling me the names of things, magic, shrouding, underwear,
you go down the cliff behind you and hug the wall, you get the 10 and tell, oh that's actually
pretty good, don't mind if I do, this one,
you said underwear, yes but be careful, okay, um, I can tell people had the same idea,
probably this one for it, what was I saying, oh, um,
what, does anybody just see me land on that top of the tree,
all right, I'll wait before I move forward, do I go to the left or do I go to the right,
I was sure, I was sure I was dead, I just like, there's like a random like thing right there,
I wonder if that's what the thing says, left, okay, thank you, let me heal, that would be smart
of me, I do like this, the flask of the, of what I have in this because it gives me like a little
bonus health, do I keep hugging the wall, where do I hear weird shit,
I know, I was like, why am I on a tree,
ah,
let's go, poggers, ah, I forgot those were there, I was not paying attention, ah,
please, deagro, deagro, deagro,
there we go, um, I'm just gonna teleport somewhere real quick,
what, what, sometimes you guys just say the most out of pocket shit, it's like
unprompted for my delicious curves, if you know what I mean, okay, okay, buddy,
um, okay, what's the name of the other, because I have, wait,
I have the grave and stool school talisman, I have that for some reason,
I don't really need the source seal anymore,
her tree by the sorrow and I, oh, okay, so you're talking about this one,
you're talking about this one,
okay, I'm gonna say it, I don't care that you broke your elbow,
all right, let's go over here, my leg is itchy,
game is to choose your own collectathon, that's a way to put it, I suppose,
uh, yeah, yeah, let me not fall off the cliff, we're falling off cliff, it's fine,
uh, okay, where is it, does the, does the thingy have it, do I have to kill the thingy for it,
do I have to kill the urgery avatar for it, yes, okay, I should probably stay in horseback to this,
um, we'll do some things for some, oh, fuck me bro, um,
I probably should have switched to my little thingy in the barber, hi, now,
I'd rather do this on foot actually,
you like rocks, I like, oh yeah, you're, you're pretty weak to rocks,
probably weak to fire too, oh, I am close to death,
let me just, I'm killing all my puppies, how dare you, how, how could you do this to me,
that's just very not nice, oh, let me just run up and, oh, that's not what I meant to,
there we go, there we are, let me just heal, let me just heal, let me just heal, let me just heal,
yeah,
I could not get out of the way, that's fine, that's fine,
there we go, I'm stuck to a rock, oh, hold on, let me just run away real quick, I am close to death,
oh my me being close to death, oh yeah, I know you can shoot me that shit,
now,
oh, don't come at me, please, don't come at me, please, don't come at me, please, no,
whoever threw that piece of paper, your mom is a hoe,
yeet,
I imagine having the, um, the fucking ability to, why are you all dancing, fucking weird,
the ability to, let me talk to you guys,
surprise, bitch,
oh, there's so fucking many of you, I wish I didn't aggro you guys,
oh, it's fine, he'll take care of them for me,
where am I, I feel like I'm on the edge of a cliff, something, something makes me feel
like I'm on the edge of a cliff, let me just have a vague feeling I'm on the edge of a cliff,
yeah, I was,
dogs, can you, can you do something about that, can you,
that's fine,
why do you have to get me right when I'm healing, can you like hit your dude, please,
instead of me, can you do that for me, I would appreciate it,
ow, can you like, I'm gonna run over to you just so you get hit now bro, oh, I'm dead, fuck,
can you get the summon of the wolves, what do you mean, I have, I literally just used the fucking
summon of the wolves, are you blind, come on, come on brother,
where am I, what the fuck,
how did I get all the way over here, what the hell, who just shot me,
who's shooting me, oh,
it's his butterfly wound, his butt is scratched,
it's fine, I can't really see that well,
oh, one disappeared, can I, I don't know why it, it's all over to me over there,
I'm just, it's there for something, literally, all right, let's go back to where we were,
bro had some aim, he did, I have a big wedgie, hold on, my fucking shorts,
where the arrow is big enough, I don't think they were, because they didn't kill me,
hey, how you doing, here, I'm just gonna aggro only you, so I don't have to deal with your boys
again, can you come over here, perfect, you don't have a face,
what's up with that, why don't you have a face bro,
yeah, I totally timed that wrong,
no,
I don't think this lock is annoying, I feel like my camera isn't doing well,
yeah, yeah, oh you killed me, what the hell, I was not paying attention to my health,
where did Muppet Chibi go, oh did you, do you miss Muppet Chibi,
I don't know why I'm losing at the fucking, I should have taken five seconds, I hate it when
I like, it's always my first attempt, I beat, like I'm so close to beating a boss,
but then I just choke the next 50 times, I don't know why that is, but it's a thing,
this happens to me, I think because I overthink it, it's the chibi syndrome,
I don't like the name of that, it's the souls game, I prefer the souls game effect,
rather than the chibi syndrome,
I creep up, I think you saw me,
you think you saw, oh there's a fucking tower in the background, I didn't notice,
oh,
oh, we both hit each other at the same time,
where am I, I can't even see when I'm next to you,
you like destroy more things, I don't have to worry about
running, backing up into shit, oh yeah, fuck, why do I do that,
I fucking missed, oh can I do it again,
I don't have anything, hold on, pardon, give me a moment,
yeah,
are you fucking kidding me bro,
did you see that shit, he one-shotted me,
how the fuck, oh my god, why do I suck at video games,
yeah f's please, f's please in chat for that, that deserved, bigger check, I know, what the hell,
game is cheating, no other options,
madden for the love of god, ah, oh fine, all right, let's rise up some puppies,
let me get off my horse, get down, all right, sick of them,
no, what's happening,
hold on, what, okay, you keep them occupied puppies, you uh, yeah,
oh no, hold on, I need to, oh, oh fuck, I missed, oh, I don't need it,
this guy's easy, I'm just being a dumbass,
yeah, you get him, one last puppy dog, oh, oh, this is awkward,
oh, please, I gotta go, I'm busy that day, oh, where am I, what the hell,
what's happening, no, he's just gonna keep spamming this at me, oh no,
no, I keep accidentally doing this to ruin tears, this is the right one, come back,
can you come down here, sir, sir, sir,
sir, can I jump up this way, can I jump up this way,
I can make it, okay,
uh,
am I stuck in a fucking tree, no, no, where am I, how do I get back up,
that was pretty, look at this dude, he's hanging out,
oh my god, okay, no, fine, that's fine, I can go over here, right, yeah, we're cool,
yeah, it's fine, oh, please don't fucking jump on me,
okay, where am I,
fine, fine, how is this, this is grace right here, I can just, I'm just gonna touch it,
I'm not gonna sit down, I don't know if the, I can't recall if it'll retain the thing,
where the fuck is this minor earth tree, where am I, I'm so far away, can I just go over here,
please, why are you jumping so far, there I am, are these guys like even like the littlest bit
perturbed, no, okay, oh, I need this actually,
um, please, please don't, I don't want to have to kill you bro, you're just not doing anything,
how are you not, what the fuck dude, I hate this,
it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine,
I know, what the fuck was up with that poise, why wait,
no, that's not what I meant to do,
hi, I'm back, it's taking me too long to fight you for no reason, I'm just bad at video games,
except I'm not the vtuber of bad at video games, you guys know what I mean,
watch me have like taken damage for that shit, I would have fucking permitted,
what the fuck, get out of the fucking way puppies,
attack,
I don't want to aggro the other guys, I'm bringing them over here,
please don't kill my puppies, the other guys are just hanging out, they're like wow, he's doing so
much, oh no, I thought you just killed me, because I heard the noise of something dying,
and it'll be really pissed, I'm out of fucking, oh run, run you motherfucker, Jesus Christ, I'm looking
at your staff like you're dumb fuck, and dodge, jeez,
just matter, just matter,
you're fucking tree, die,
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, why can't I beat this fucking tree,
I'm just gonna play monster hunter, a thousand, no actually pay off my debt, give me $8,000 please,
I'm on my deforestation,
okay cool, I have no money but it's nice to know, thank you,
do you hate monster hunter, no, I just, I don't really care about monster hunter that much,
if someone says how much money to do anything, I'm going to just say the same amount, sorry,
I'm so sorry Torrent for that,
stop playing stupid as I get hit, back up, back up, back up,
I don't know how I made that, I'm gonna fall off, I just fucking know it, you're gonna back me to a
fucking corner, you stop,
I'm gonna, I don't have any dogs, I don't have any dogs,
where am I,
I can never fucking dodge this in time, I swear to god,
oh fuck you, I'm going back over here,
oh fucking, oh, oh,
you're knocking your own trees over bro,
oh,
my game is lagging, what was that,
stab, stab, stab, stab,
no,
I'm gonna fall off the fucking cliff again,
no, it's fine,
oh
you like get stunned or something, like what the fuck is wrong with you,
why do you keep doing this, I don't,
I'm literally trying to fucking dodge,
can we not die,
you just
no,
he's gonna die, please, Jesus Christ,
thank you,
no, damn you, it gives you a lot of tears, um, anyways,
that took way too fucking long, first try everybody, first try, I should have been the
first try, again, I almost always kill shit in the first try,
actually you know where I'm gonna go,
yeah, yeah, also when I play Elden Ring, I just get distracted and I need to get
shit done, GV syndrome strong, zero deaths, I feel like watching a zero death Elden Ring run,
ah, EG,
oh, I did it,
now we're at five,
okay,
fuck,
because I like, oh, I don't,
wait, did I just do that, I just do that correctly, no, I don't,
lies of PTSD, lies of P wasn't even bad compared to Elden Ring, it's really not,
yeah, it's really not,
it's also, I liked lies of P because I think I liked how linear it was,
now everything loops back around pretty easily,
I want sheepies to moonvail me, moonvail you anytime baby girl, my baby doll,
that's where I missed all the time, you guys baby doll, all right,
we're going to the Starfall Crater, let's go,
yeah, was it, is today the last day of the steam sale, steam sale,
you guys know what I mean,
probably didn't either, I'm probably going to see if I just ran straight, but I'm stupid,
so you never know, alerted, alerted, oh, it's a fucking bear,
I just like to see stuff, I just like to grab stuff that close,
hey, Wolfie boy, where are you at, PewDiePie,
it's a crater, oh,
I'm,
jangering it,
it ended five or four hours ago, okay,
yeah, we're going to jump off this cliff, let's fucking do it,
it's a message today, oh, something incredible, you guys ready,
I didn't want to jump off the cliff, it was impulsive, I knew I was going to die,
I just really wanted to do it,
zero deaths, zero deaths, zero deaths,
and call the void is strong, right, you just want to throw yourself into it,
am I going to grab my little, my little runes that I left behind,
I need to grab my little runes, where is it,
why can't I, why is discord telling me to DM people, you just added this person as a friend,
you should DM them, I don't, I was like, that should just be circumvented from when I actually
have a call with them, every game we're just going to have to jump off a cliff,
a 4,000 wow, all right, I forgot how to get down here, let me just,
may call me itchy,
So pretty, wow, wow, oh, there it is, the stream chat froze.
What do you expect me to do about that?
I don't know what to tell you, brother.
I don't know what to tell you, you guys broke my chat.
What am I supposed to do?
How could you do this?
Oh my god, it's gone, you destroyed it, I fixed it, it's fine.
I can't believe you've done this, you guys really wanted to read what you were saying.
Don't forget, everything when I play video games is your fault.
I'm just gonna, yeah, this is fine, isn't it?
Don't die.
Cool, nice, cool, nice, cool, nice, cool, what the fuck are people falling off over
here before?
I don't want to see what this person did.
Girl, why are you pissing so loud, Reina's just about, oh, they just, what do they think
they were gonna do?
Reina is pissing in that little box, alright, is this the only way to go?
Alright, chicken, no jumping ahead, underground required ahead, yeah, no shit, try jumping,
it says no jumping, try jumping.
Funny, like, how would anyone make that jump is so funny to me.
That's Reina, she'd be pissing, there's so much fog, what does it say?
You're not wrong, oh shit, jumping off required ahead, down, we're going down, down, in an
early year round, why are you, do you bring me to the bathroom?
Are you just like standing or sitting right now, just like pissing with me and your hand
on your phone?
That's crazy, can't believe you, which way do I go?
Not this way, that's for sure, I don't believe it's that way, definitely this way, oh, I
made it, I'm a platformer, bye Torrent, thank you for the lift, okay, alright, there's bitches
down there, I know there'll be bitches.
So, Sofra is my favorite area, and my least favorite area at the same time, it's my favorite
area because of how gorgeous it is that in Noskilla, whatever it's called, you know,
I should probably get a lantern, it's too late now, it's too late now, oh look, pick
one up right here, can't I, I don't even have a torch, it's fine, should have gotten like
a stupid lantern, someone's shooting me, something incredible ahead, therefore try attacking, what,
is there a hidden door, you fucking liar, it's just a wee bit dark, we're just, we're
making this into a horror game, don't worry about it, don't worry about it, where did
she come from, where did she go, I'm fine, where did she come from, nice girl, Lokron,
eternal city, I am being raided by the strony, hello, hello, how was your time with strony,
I am in Lokron, I'm trying to get the mimic here, how was the stream, how are you doing,
I'm your girl, it's your girl, skinny penis, to me you should be cotton bomb, platforming,
I'm not good at it, death, ow wait you're still alive, motherfucker, oh no you're not,
who's alive, it's you, hold on I'm scratching my eye, I got the model working with the other, yeah,
it actually works fine, I thought it my computer wasn't gonna be able to handle it because it
couldn't handle wolf quest, but it just, you know, it is what it is, what was my crouching
ahead, what, oh I get it, probably really shouldn't, oh heal until I need to, what are you doing
over here dude, stop it, stop, probably lock on, it's fine, um, what am I doing,
wolf quest probably unoptimized, frame cap and discord, oh kisses my floppy ears, oh, ah,
blushes, immensely, I'll take this little piece of poop, thank you, oh no, no, I still have an
arrow in my fucking leg, hey, hold on, my nose is itchy, can I pause, that's not a thing in this
game, you're gonna have to give me a moment, give me a moment, give me just a moment, I know I
don't have to kill them because I'm just usually just speedrunning, but I just really wanted to,
you know, there's a guy behind me, I know that much, it's a nascent butterfly, get away,
did anybody, did anybody, oh did he fall off, he did, I also forget the way to go to get them
here, I think I just have to fall like the game, my game keeps like lagging a little bit though,
I don't know why this is happening, I think it's just like loading on all the fucking asses,
oh, they're fucking superhero landed, alert, I will tarnish, you can pause it, but no, I don't
need to pause it, I almost said I don't need to tarnish, you'll, what's the dog doing?
What's up, you literally just like pissed so loudly, I really hope you don't have piss on your
butt, because I'll be very upset with you young lady, he's like squeaked at me, you guys couldn't
hear it though, she's like parkour, parkour, parkour, what even is this rock damage,
I'm trying to do stuff, what are you guys, can you guys like just chill out,
oh my god, take whatever this is, I don't know why it looked like blighty, just got back, cool,
alrighty then, erm, debating whether or not to quickly look up a thing, because I forget
where this motherfucker is, oh nice, I need that, what are you doing,
being beat up with a guy with only a shield, I don't really need to chill out, how random
just stepped on my boob, you know options menu, open up your help menu and the game pauses,
oh really, that's funny, I don't want to go anywhere, I don't want to like send myself
into a fucking circle, where the fuck did you just drop them, this dude over here, this wise guy,
can you leave me alone, are you guys looking at nothing, are you saying no, alright cool,
crap is down there, yeah I know, I'm just seeing if there's anything else around that I want to
snag before I go, like some of these, I'm going to mine if I do, yep,
sorry, pardon me, please stop chasing me with your shield, it's really nice, I'm just not interested,
I got a gamer it up, oop oop, tasty, because like I remember doing like stepping out here
and I was like holy shit, like it's just so gorgeous, it's so fuck, I have to fight a boss, oh man,
god damn it, I had to fight, what is it, the ancestral, what the hell, I totally forgot
that you were here, I remember I got your helmet before and I like it a lot,
finally catching out during streams, all the vods enjoyed them, your perseverance against
market, the worm, and I'm just going to start bad riffle, maybe for your head, try confidence one,
oh wait is that the mimic tier, is the mimic tier the next one,
yeah okay, hold on,
damn,
I like finance fuck, what's that, oh it's that dude, who's that guy,
yeah I'm built, I'm fucking, I'm a tank bro,
you see these skills,
what do you mean demonetized, I'm fine,
hey,
cool, all right give me like a quick second,
yeah, fuck,
can you like hold on a moment, I'm trying to do shit,
look at me just chasing myself,
I know the inventory is the actual boss,
they're like oh fuck, she's throwing rocks at me, this is what is that a thing,
can I just, I just want to be able to equip,
no let's not, I don't want the fucking rat against sore seal, what,
I'm in a corner, oh,
oh hold on,
no it's not what I want,
it's hard to do this at the same time,
can I put some shoes on now,
I don't know where I got exile grapes from but,
oh, they're throwing a fucking rock at me, no I still need to equip my,
these don't kill me, I don't mean to be locked on you, oh no momento,
cool, that's fun, all right,
what, how can I heal, I have nothing to heal with, how did I do that,
fuck off, oh my god,
unironically first try,
listen man, I don't know what to tell you,
I'm just doing what I'm doing,
you know, it just, it just be that you be doing stuff,
and that, yeah, you know, it just, it just be, it just do, it just be, it just is,
all right,
I bullied the four, four thing,
why is everybody mad that I killed a naked version of myself,
all right, I recall, if I, if I can recall correctly, the mimic tear is somewhere
in that castle place and it's guarded by two ladies, I'm probably totally wrong,
I'm gonna kill, why are there birds down here, to make that make sense, that's my question,
sorry I was killing birds,
is that right, the bird was confused, hold up, I need to, they flew down, you know, they just,
they were just flying down,
Rena, it's very hard to do this with you in my lap,
I have a stone key, so that's fine, I don't know, guys, I don't remember,
find building rooftops to enter night's sacred ground, fight more mimics,
find the nox sword, yeah, it's a nox sword stress,
yeah, but let me see the fucking, give me a video,
hug left, and then, you know what, I'll trust, I'm gonna trust you guys,
Rena, you're so cute, oh my god, she's rumbled so much louder,
I'm gonna trust Rena, stop eyeballing my headphones, she's just like really looking at it,
like she really wants to bite them, stop, stop it, I just said you were cute,
all right, let, I'm gonna trust you guys, you're gonna direct me, I'm gonna,
I'm literally gonna follow your directions, because I can't remember what this thing is,
okay, I need to like,
I'm giving you another chance, walk forward five paces, one, two, three, four, five,
that's kind of a, let's do that, oh what's this,
I jumped out here,
you guys don't even know where the fuck I'm going, oh my god, great,
walk away until you find, you guys are just terrible at describing things, that's what I've learned,
can I, I can't use torrent on here, can I, oh I can, sorry,
so get down off the bridge safely, and hug the left of the forest, okay, hello little deer,
hug the left of the forest, right now you're falling off,
left of the forest, left, oh shit, left of the forest, staying on the left of the forest,
the left of the, oh that worked, the left of the forest, oh yeah, there's a fucking dog around here,
I just remembered, is it over here, oh give me that, okay I'm at the grace,
there's people looking at me, I don't like how they're reaching out, explain that, now it's parkour,
from here you get to platform, all right,
looks like somebody died, not me though, I don't die,
hardcore parkour, can I just jump off onto that guy, that'd be nice,
all righty, all righty, all righty, I feel like I already fucked up, no I didn't, you,
maybe, I mean to be fair you did charge a horse off of a ledge onto your rooftop,
so find a path that deviates toward the left and parkour left with some nipple chimneys
onto a lower area, I like the description, some nipple chimneys, how do I fucking,
go back, go right, oh you're right, yep, yep, yep, uh huh, yes, oh it's all coming back to me now,
oh yes I recall, I am recalling immensely,
yep, yep, yes, why are people dying,
there's a fucking, oh there's, aren't there goblins here,
well,
are you, hold on a moment, I'm gonna grab whatever this is,
yeah I don't go that way, I just go, I just go straight right, sorry I'm gonna hide behind this
dead dude, two human shaped mimics on this area, yep, yes this is the path forward or left and
below are the boob chimneys, go straight where the mimic is, okay that's what I thought, booby chimneys,
oh my god, Jesus fuck, booby chimneys,
booby chimneys, did you just, oh, that was weird, what the hell,
booby chimneys,
can you get a famous jump, that's fine,
I think when I played the game I honestly only fell off of that like once,
booby chimneys, straight, alrighty,
oh my god, okay,
then left,
hello, is anybody here,
yeah it's a really short odd jump, oh nice,
on the left, what, you mean, I mean are you talking about this room,
progress, I thought, hey lady, yeah, I know you bed, yeah,
don't attack me yet,
I'm just gonna, and now I'm gonna,
I don't really do much to you,
okay, oh, I don't know why I'm still attacking, oh,
oh don't kill me, oh she killed me,
fucking love her whip, that's me for real for real,
she is the true Elden Lord,
okay,
the Domino's Stella, okay hold on, give me a second,
hey, yeah, okay, quite true,
hey, doobie doobie doobie,
hey, yeah, hey, yeah,
for 10 more, last school, where am I going, I'm going this way,
go down, go ninja, go ninja, go, oh my god,
are we helpful, you did it, I'm so proud, my headphones are falling out,
and that's why I almost, I almost died,
Reina, don't shoot him, Reina, don't do it, Reina,
now I'm just resting my controller on Reina,
you're falling, okay, perfect, now I can use Reina as an armrest,
hold that for me, she's on my lap,
I call that give you one every time,
I don't have 2,000 rooms, Reina please don't headbutt me,
wow, we zowie, anyways,
cool,
mimic two ashes, oh, thanks Reina, I just ripped out my headphones and
blew my ear drums out, why is there garlic hanging from the ceiling,
what is that, bones,
pearls, stones, her stuff, it's stuff, I thought it was garlic,
from here you want to head into the hallway and out the window,
all right, why is there just a random spinning stone here,
I'll kill you just because,
out the window, what window,
remember to kill the ball, why would I kill the ball, the ball's hanging out,
he's doing his own thing,
aha, wait that's not right, aha, I look to the left, cool, all right,
kapao,
kopee,
it's over for thee
and me,
it should add a jump over ledge, no because I thought it was like a sloping roof that I
could just drop down to, that was funny,
kopee,
no,
no, my runes, all right, I don't need to be here anymore, it's fine,
I know I parkour too hard, I don't even need to be here,
how the fuck do I get out,
fuck, I have to continue to leave, yeah I just wanted to mimic here,
what the fuck was that, I just did a weird drop roll in there,
all right, yeah let's just, let's just, let's head over to the artist shack,
all right,
we made it,
yeah mandatory if you summon mimic you didn't beat the game, that's so stupid,
yeah I should probably get a lantern,
where are the lanterns, can I, I can buy it from uh, what's this face, can I,
oh that's not what I wanted,
what the fuck am I doing,
it's a merchant in South Eler Eurnia, it's not, I thought Ella had it,
I mean, what the fuck this dude's name is,
no, oh he has a torch, that's what he has,
I can use a telescope,
get a cool chain quaff,
for now,
uh, South Eurnia,
if you use any other weapon than dagger or use any armor you cheat,
it's the isolated merchant, I thought you said it was Eurnia,
because is it the dude over here, no, is it the dude over here, where,
where do I go,
bottom left island, over here,
in the, where the dragon shit is,
that left shirt, what,
left side, oh so over here,
you guys are giving me multiple things, you're giving me Eler Eurnia and you're giving me
even peninsula,
I'll have to start calling on you and be like you there, you tell me where to go,
because everybody else is, then I'll give it to somebody else another turn,
hello,
I remember trying to fight this like one dude forever on the beach,
I don't know who it was,
all the beach south, I'm going north,
other direction, I did it,
maybe I like to do things the hard way,
look at these guys, they're just, they're just hanging out,
they're just doing guy things, they're literally just like,
why are there so many of them by the beach, I always wondered that,
is this just so you could practice like giant crowd spells or attacks,
maybe, I don't know, it's a casual beach party,
let's go to the beach,
beach, Ninky Minjaj,
oh hey, isn't this what the shrimp guy is, the prawn guy, the shrimp prawn guy too,
bye, you have a nice outfit,
do you cover your face completely,
at the end of the day, I would like to buy one lantern,
one moment, just give me a second, I swear I have money,
I'm sorry my card's not working,
it's gonna work in just a second, I swear to god,
give me, give me a moment,
I should have done that one, I should have done that one,
2,500, how much was it,
what was it, I think it was 1,800, I already forgot,
we're gonna, we'll leave him a tip, you know, we'll leave him,
fuck, we'll leave him a tip, sorry, I'm trying to talk to you,
yeah, sorry I'm like making you look over your shoulder,
what,
those ashes of, oh, the Zwei Handar, colossal sword,
sacrificial twig, what you guys are except it's sacrificial twink,
yeah, you know, you got your lantern, I should probably put that to someplace else,
2,000, magnificent weapon,
all right, so we got the Mimic Tear,
I don't have a lot of glove wart, I think I only have like,
why, I hate that sometimes I like to mark it, life is robots,
is Roderica doing shit now, no, she's just being weird, can you like,
oh, sorry, we have to talk to fucking Master Hugue, damn it, I'm going the wrong way,
Hugue, Hugue, balls, I'm going the wrong way, I told you guys, I just get lost,
Hugue, that's the two fingers, you spin me right around,
baby right around, Hugue, what's in here, oh it's Fia, Fia, hi Fia,
hi,
here's the homie, here's question line next for Nagakiba and the
anti-mogue bullshit crystal, yes, you're right, I want to hug Fia but she debuffs me,
I forget, how do you get, doesn't she give you something to get rid of the debuff,
I forget, the blessing, okay,
I sort of way,
Fia, oh, the lovely hug,
I'm in a cold suit of armor but thank you,
what is a bald again,
you take me in your pants,
no, I didn't want to go, why is everybody so weirdly fucking proportioned,
besides our own character, our heads are so small,
oh,
call me dear, yeah, yeah, yeah,
you're on the top,
my second never wants to repeat the fraction I was going over here,
oh, I'm not dead, Rodriguez,
I love their like friendship, like his fatherly affection for her, it's very sweet,
Why do you have chains on your legs?
It's like, why are you so ugly?
You know, just ask people why they have chains on their legs and why they're ugly.
I'm going to kill this guy, because I feel like it.
Oh, I got a new member.
Welcome. Welcome to the harem.
Are there any details to pay attention to the forces of our life at this time?
You guys are the real one.
Oh, nice.
I got one of those.
Isn't that like late game? I forget.
Ugh, weird.
I got that boom boom pow.
Oh, we're both going to kill each other?
Yeah.
Stop.
Don't heal again, you motherfucker.
I have frostbite.
Stop it.
No, you don't get to kill me.
No.
What?
I threw my controller across the room. I don't know if you guys hear it, heard it.
No, I think it kind of just like rolled over my couch to be honest with you, then plopped on the ground.
Looks like we have a new throne entry.
No, I need to add, what's it called?
Am I throne? I usually get new joy cons because I have six drifts.
I'm going to go grab my controller.
Thank you.
Oh, are you taking care of this one?
Okay, a little ruffle of your process.
Alright, where'd it go?
Oh, over here.
Hi, Raina.
Are you like, ended up in your general direction?
I'm going to get on the stretch.
Yeah.
You want to stretch me?
Yeah, all of you.
You didn't do the stretching, did you?
Oh, you can see it.
Hi, Raina.
I know you're here. I just saw you, Raina.
I thought you were being fake.
Here, you're looking a little bit chunky.
What's that, Raina?
Why do you look so large?
Here, why do you look a little funny?
It's because we're done.
Come here.
You look like you're taking over this world.
It was raised alongside dogs,
but under a rescuer,
and sometimes she curls her tail over her back.
I mean...
Yeah, can you do a big stretch?
Yeah, a lot of big stretch.
Yeah?
Raina, stretch!
She did it.
She got up on her tippy toes and stretched her up real long.
You guys missed it.
Sorry.
Why do I have in my box of Korean food?
Fuck away from here.
No, is this a shiho right?
I'm fine.
What's in here?
I got...
They're all just like pastry things.
Victory pie.
Ooh, a victory pie.
I should eat a victory pie.
I'll eat this victory pie.
The vic pie.
That's a weird-looking thing on it.
After I beat the fucking mad tone,
al-bar-la-la-la-la.
I'm about to go mono-e-mono.
My headphones are off.
I need to plug in my controller again.
Oh, my God.
She said, call that dolphin kitty.
My cat used to do that. That's cute.
If you're confident, you can get replacement choices
whether they be cheap or expensive.
You don't know what you're doing.
What?
Placement joysticks?
You want me to take apart my controller?
You want me to take apart my Joy-Con?
I'm smart, but I'm not that smart.
See, it works fine.
My PlayStation controller works fine.
I'll break. I come to bargain.
I'll take this, though.
You don't get to stun-lock me, dude.
No.
What the fuck?
What the hell?
I want a scythe.
Where do I get this fucking scythe?
Oh, my God. He's going to kill me again.
I got frostbite.
Why don't you fucking heal?
Yeah.
Motherfucker.
Yeah, you don't have any more, bitch.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck. Oh, shit.
But I have more.
Because I'm that bitch.
Anyways.
Is that the meta in the PvP?
I never ever play PvP.
Is that the meta?
Did this be a door?
I don't know. You tell me.
Stole his tongue.
Mmm.
Time for this victory pie.
It looks really gross.
Ew.
It smells bad.
Is it supposed to be strawberry flavored?
It has a giant V on it.
For Veeler.
It's a calming bad tongue as well.
I found madness to break PvP,
at least when I'm getting invaded.
Oh, nice.
Mmm.
It doesn't taste good.
Oh, thanks.
I'm good. Oh, thank you.
Damn.
You write a whole fucking essay
on the four agreements, bro?
Jesus Christ.
I just had to read it.
That's okay. I don't need this.
I like Stormville.
I mean Stormville. I like Moonville.
Sexy.
I am sexy.
What are you doing?
Okay, is there a better snack in here
that is actually tasty?
Is this coffee?
Or coffee flavored?
It's like a wafer.
I can't get it out.
Oh.
It is coffee flavored.
It's actually not bad.
Interesting.
Kind of tweaking my mind out,
because I feel like I'm drinking coffee,
but I'm eating a biscuit.
Brother writing a thesis.
I usually don't like coffee flavored things.
I just prefer to drink coffee.
Lever or lever? Why?
I haven't had tiramisu in a long time.
Espresso mixed into chocolate
goes pretty hard.
I thought it was a party hard.
Too bad the place I bought the front was down.
Oh, that's too bad.
Look at all these
overgrown swords.
Pickle?
Aren't the flower up there?
Read message.
I want to roll into the fire.
Let's me roll into the fire.
What am I doing next?
I'm sorry.
I immediately turned when I saw it.
It was kind of funny.
I'm getting
the
Mogue tier.
Where's the Mogue tier?
I'm going to go over here and I'm going to grab that.
I'm going to go to the Ertree Gazing Hill.
What is this?
I'm literally just taking a bite of things
and then throwing it away.
Why is everything like a fig Newton?
What is supposed to be in the middle of this?
Why is it spicy?
Am I allergic?
I don't think I like that.
I'm covered in crumbs.
No, I think I'll be good.
Oh, shit. Why did I not see this before?
Hello?
Why did I not grab that?
I think I have enough to level up.
No.
No, I don't.
I know there's some in the center.
Exactly, Boomi.
Oh, am I allergic?
No.
Hi.
Are you headbutting the box?
What's up?
Did you want it?
I was going to headbutt me.
You chewed this box, by the way.
Oh, my main main.
Oh, such a big head.
Yeah.
What are you chewing on the box?
He's a dog.
Puppy?
You're a little puppy?
You're a little puppy dog?
Boomi, are you teasing?
Baby?
I actually still have Boomi's first baby tooth,
just like a mom.
I regret where I put it, though.
Is that it?
No.
Welcome.
Day two of stream watching.
Welcome, welcome.
So,
let me go grab this.
Here.
That's all the way over there.
At least I can see where the fuck I'm going.
I can also
kill some fire monks
so I can be
more resistant
to fire magic myself.
I might do that
when I find some of my farm some fire monks.
Monks? Monks?
Why am I saying monks?
What the fuck is wrong with me?
I don't have my headphones in,
so I can't tell if anything's attacking me or not.
I'm not sure if the music's just changed.
I should probably put my thumb in.
Missed the Furpy App hour because you were asleep?
No worries.
We still yapping, we still having a good time.
I was eating soup.
You missed the soup, bro.
Let's get rid of Radon's Rune or keep the Godric one.
I forget what Radon's Rune does.
I didn't even go to the tower for his Rune.
So,
let me see.
Yeah, see, I can't.
I haven't gotten it benedicted yet.
It's best for a late game.
Increases health, fp, and endurance by 10%.
I hate that.
It isn't just a standard status.
You have to pop it, the Rune, to use it.
I'll be honest with you,
when I beat the game, I never even used great runes.
I never factored those into my builds.
I'm going the wrong way.
Excuse me.
I don't mind you guys educating me on great runes.
Where is it?
It's over here.
I was some time.
It was very rarely.
It was a random thing rolling down the way.
Let's get it honestly same bro I already grabbed the one over here oh no I didn't
don't mind if I do you wink there's a lot of golden seeds over here
alrighty somebody stop me this is gonna be I remember this was a bitch to get to
why did I teleport over there it doesn't matter
it's not like these bitches respawn again I hope not
can't actually cry yep yep excuse me little slug
hey isn't there must be an invader now isn't there oh there's a lot of dead
people in here I'm fine
you're missing that fight no doctor version I need to get over there to
matter raw I need to go this way that's what I need to do me actually yep sorry
again I just like to see where the fuck I'm going then I need to go up actually
it's too far away
so quick run around the little drainage ditch with explosions let's do it
actually before I do that let me pop a squat real quick I swear I had a three
golden seeds but I guess I fucking don't I thought I had three because I thought I
too and we'll not from before but I know but alright excuse me sheepies excuse me
and the bed but uh oh you may plus just announce my participation in the
should I call it their concerts watch along you son of a bitch you son of a
bitch how dare you how dare you cross my path not let me hit you properly
yeah blood blade fabulous
you
wrong way what do you mean
what do you mean
oh there's a fucking bridge ah I forgot it's a bridge
I mean this goes to the shaded castle I'm just trying to find this little oh fuck
I'm not in the mood bro anyways
spirit spring where is it I've never heard it called it spirit spring
boomi I can feel you wanting to jump up on my desk I can see you at the corner
my oh there he is hi no you don't get to try to lick the bowl that my soup was
in come snuck why don't you just think snuck that stomping on my boot I don't
see I'm trying to shoot at me yeah
we
when I'm like the bowl he's like really trying to get to it can you get down I'm
gonna squirt you in the bum hole okay thank you
pointing that thing right at me I don't want to see his nasty butt
yep
all right all right crossover here yippie zippy
did I get it
oh all right that guy's dead it's fine we're just gonna follow this path to
greatness and we're not gonna worry about these bitches they're doing their
own thing that's good on them
nope not if I have anything to say about it oh my god there's so fucking many of
them oh perfect all right we're doing good I think I can't really tell there's
a dude that drops down from somewhere I'm pretty sure oh fuck oh why'd you have
to do that wait when there's a dog there
I'm scared on a stasya I'm severely underleveled for this I was gonna run away
I don't even know where the fuck I'm going I'm not going the right way
oh
is there anything in here fabulous wonderful nothing oh what's that golden valve
I don't use incantations but thank you
what do you mean I'm passing everything
hug right for ladder
now
the other right so my left
what do you mean
ah I'm doesn't matter I'm dead
the other I'm just getting the map fragment oh I hate all of you Jesus fuck you guys are
terrible giving directions you helped me before what happened
what happened no because if I call on people people are gonna be little whiny bitches about it
I mean oh madam they call my name if they call this person's name
I'm angry I just want the fucking map
so
yeah I don't know why you guys are doing using it because you're using
north east and west before and south and that was helpful
hmm
oh why is that am I gonna die
I hate their little comies they drop everywhere yeah there's nowhere else to go for here so
that's fucking stupid
it'd be easier to try this one as course for the teleport there
what's up
you guys aren't helping me
why are you scared stop being scared stop being a little bitch Jesus
imagine goon maxing so hard your blood gets replaced by that that's fun
so
come on vamanos fucking cheap please everybody let's go come on let's get to it I know that we
can do it
join at a great time I am going so if I cross the bridge
which way do I fucking there's a crab which way do I go
so
stop thinking your bell at me dude it's inappropriate
oh
ladder on the side of the mountain
there's a fucking grace right here and I didn't even notice
free child and touch grace
left
what do you mean left
there's not a ladder here there's a ladder where the virgins are so if I hug this wall
there's a ladder
you're digging your bell
you can ring my bell
all right I'm hugging left I'm hugging it
if you look up I can see oh there it is
oh that was close let me do this
ha ha oh wait no you can hit me up here
ha ha no you can't fucking bitches ha ha whores you can't hit me you can't climb
because you don't have legs you little bitches
Jesus fuck how tall is his ladder
think of the content I think of the content if I just somehow fell
I just walked backwards and fell to my death all right also go left for free somber six
yeah oh perfect there's a thing up here
what if someone wasn't well nobody that's not what the context is so shut up I can't pick the
shit up because you're pissing me off
grave robbing with the homies
please jump higher oh you just hanging out with your dog oh
that's too bad
is this cat boy I don't know what's it
all right
if the dog doesn't get hit doesn't hit you if you don't hit them oh really
damn that's fucked oh I'm mad at myself now I didn't know that um
just go forward and climb ladders up
okay if you insist there's a lot of dead people
I don't see ladders I don't see ladders here guys
I just see pumpkin heads
is this a ladder is this what they call a ladder these days or is this what the kids are calling a
ladder there's a ladder right there
all right I'm just gonna blame you guys for everything
oh no the wolves are coming for me
I started really fucking pouring
oh look it's a it's a door can I go in hello howdy
what I don't even know where I am sorry I just wanted to open that just looked very
openable what's up there just like ear but hole very openable what what the hell
why that wolf just kick off so weirdly where do I go if you see rainbow stones on the ledge
somewhere have a closer look rainbow stones on a ledge are you serious
brother what
hug left
okay I'm gonna stand right here and I'm gonna ask you do you want me to what
go north and hug
the left cliff face thank you use the cardinal directions everybody
hugging the cliff face I'm hugging it so deeply and tenderly oh that's where the
fucking something is what's that the fuck
I'll pick this up what is it why can't I pick it up
why can't I what is this what the fuck is this what do you mean oh no I've never seen these before
what do you mean here we go
what are you guys talking about
what's this what
feed the way to what for riches oh
what what do you mean I'm dead
soul series secret
I only saw two all right
Elmo's world
oh my one more
she did it
noney yeah he thought you guys fucking thought they're like oh madams gonna freak out when this thing
shows up nah bro I played souls games before I played this before I'm no bitch I'm no bitch
I am no bitch that's not it what do you mean that's not it
she doesn't know what do you mean
oh you guys are annoying
um
let's fucking talk
I know there's like more dudes up here I don't know what they are though
you guys are you guys are bitches
uh I remember there is a guy at the top of this uh I forget it's like the night star
beast right which I love they're like one of my favorite things in the game
uh
careful on the left of the ladder
what oh I forgot they can climb
um there's something over here I can't quite recall
oh
man you're doing stuff oh what's that
what road do I oh grace reach out and touch grace oh no I guess I can't
la la la la la la I'm still being followed by them
I'm gonna sit down and quickly dagger them visions of fight
I am quite close I can smell it
oh
why is there a ladder and then why is there
y'all
hello night star beast
or falling star beast whatever your fold
now what's that
la la la la
uh I forget there's a way for me to get down from here
yes here it is
yeah guys you don't think I know I know the following star beast was at the top of mount
gun oh fuck mount gelmere I already knew that ooh give me that boomie are you okay
why are you me yowing what's up ah it's fucking bopped me
nope
can I
oh yeah there's a dude over here boomie what's the matter
the troll
or it's the blight dude what what's the matter sweetheart what's up
why are you meowing no attention do you never do that never do that for attention
what's up you want to go into the box look at my dude don't have one
um
gave me that are you gonna nest into
you can't even get into the box boomie you're too big
boomie you're not a kitten anymore you can't just like crawl into small boxes
a bop and a bap a bop a bap is like a a bap is light what the fuck is this guy doing
it took him a while uh
uh
and i'm dead um
a bop is a slight uh is harder than a bap a bap is like a a bop is like a
a bop is like a a bap is like a like a you know
you're just smacking my microphone boomie what's the matter
i think he's just jealous because i've been on the computer lately so much
he's not used to it he's like what the fuck mother
why don't you go play with fia why don't you go lay down you're the only one that's
like super active rain is taking a nap fia is taking a nap you're trying to climb into this box
here i'll help you i'll hold it i'll hold the side flap down for you
go on climb into the box you're too big for it oh you're doing these pictures
my little needy boy just like you guys
mother what happened to pre debut what do you mean
oh i am that bitch
i think i can use gravity magic on this thing
oh that's all the right way hello
ow ow please don't kill me i just got here
i'll be taking this
um let's not fall off the side i forget the blight dudes here
ah you are standing on my boobs
this is not comfortable for me sir
are you just gonna plop you're just plopping on me okay out you're snapping on my nipple
please stop stomping on my boobies booby just lay in the bed i'm begging you
okay here let me hold you for a moment
are you feeling better
if you just want to be held
he's doing like the softest tiniest little rumbles
can you make him bisque from me
you're making biscuits who are you
he has his priority straights when we use charmers to be effective
you're shedding a lot i should brush you
i'm just laying here to pause for all
okay i gave you smooches i gave you twitches and pets are you good now
this is so weird he's usually not this needy and wanting to snuggle it's so funny to me
i feel like he just doesn't know how to ask to snuggle if he just like acts out
oh he's dead yet you just don't know how to ask that you want to be held
is your little baby
why is your mouth open his eyes are closed and his mouth is just open he's like
oh okay you just want to get him attention
yeah he used to be such a snuggly kitten but then he just stopped and now he's like
you know he's trying to be smuggly again
boomie isn't annoying he's just a menace to society isn't that right he is your boy
you're just a menace to society just wants his head pat
okay i'm gonna put you look bad
you can hang out okay why don't you just hang out mister
why don't you guys lay down in the bed on my desk
your you smell did you just fart on me oh my god
he farted on me when he laughed it smelled like tuna
we act out do we get cuddles well no you're not a kitten oh excuse me uh
there's another talker it's down here
thank you
yay get me out of here
unless you want me to go through and see the blight guy oh
there's a there's a grace right here actually
oh that feels so much better it just looks better guys i'm sorry
it just it bothers me when i can't see what's happening
yes he does give you a larval here um
settle for a ball my profile picture he used to do the same thing in attention
yes you what would he do he let us think if fia does it all the time
she's just like will fart out on me and then she'll like look at me all like lovingly
and i'm like girl are you serious this smells horrible
um voice protection farts refuses to elaborate leave
also can i go to sleep in your bed since i'm a kitten
sure if you guys i'll dress you up as little kittens and you guys can hang out
you guys can curl up at my feet or if you want to be a dog
somehow none of my cats have ever farted on me i wonder why
why are you sad about that cat farts are just as bad and stinky as dog farts
the hell is happening behind me this thing is just like on fire killing itself
i don't even where is it hanging from i never even noticed or did come up from the ground
anyways we did it thank you guys for your guidance uh much appreciated
what are we doing
yeah it's like fish it's like fishy gross farts
um why do i have oh it's over here that's a shady castle
sorry guys we're trying to like speedrun get to the dlc with the okay build so that's over too
second church america for purified blood crystal tear where is the second church america it is
isn't it right here where's it right here ever get i know one of the easy get the black knife at
yeah i'm gonna go like all around
left why do you say left there's nothing over here like i'm just gonna look at a fucking
yeah see west thank you in person
it's this one
there there uh there there i like what if i was over here when you said there i'd be like oh like
right here like guys there is a slight like a like couple seconds delay jesus christ uh so that's
that one why is it showing me another one is there okay no there's only show me one okay uh let's go
lovin us oriba
this i'm gonna fucking kill myself trying to get down from here aren't i like this i'll take that
mm string blow me some string uh shut up the little goblins nope nope
actually is there a firemonk in here uh is there anything here
uh
the hell shooting at me
oh that's what it is yep there's nothing over here though
uh
Elmo's world welcome oh i have a troll's golden sword you guys gonna be able to hit me
uh i have reduvia i did grab reduvia
la la la i'm looking for some firemonks not you fuck off
chat's become using really descriptive words like this one or that one
sir elinor doesn't spawn if you're still in the lake uh isn't that the twin blade
i don't need i have like i have moon veil i don't think i need a twin blade
i do like elinor's twin blade though i didn't use that for a little bit in game
um i can jump down from here right it's safe no that's fine pretty
yelp
what what are you doing here what are you
can you stop i'm not i'm too young for this i never consented to this
i forgot it was this motherfucker yet to kill it for
the tear for mog what
i'll just fucking kill yura for the naga naga kiba but i don't need it
i need to do yura's quest in order to get that tear
you have to kill elinor for the tear
thank you stop telling me to kill yura yura didn't do shit to me elinor on the other hand
i'll try to kill but uh in fact that that let me switch hands
can you get more sorceries too guys recommend some sorceries uh can you come back
oh there she is
no this isn't elinora though
this isn't elinora
go to the academy
why the fuck am i here
for night comet
no oh that's
it's that kills you very well i'm almost there
fuck off dogs
how
i need to kill this dog let me go on the other side real quick and hopefully the dog will stay on me
the dog in them
so
oh no not two fucking dogs she fucking summoning them what's happening here
oh i forgot i didn't have my shit on
oh
so
wasn't the wrong button no fuck off puppies
oh okay well that killed you
oh wait i want to try this out i don't die first
why did you oh i have fucking reduvia stuck in my fucking arm because i'm like why
when i drank that did reduvia pop up
oh puppy
i have to be like facing her
oh
don't you fucking kill me i swear to god
what
what did i pick up what they dropped
i just
did something just bug out
the fuck
i saw something drop but i ran away from the dog because it was gonna kill me
because she drops her sword she drops her sword
unless i'm fucking blind and i just don't see it the dog ate it
it's gonna punch this dog
yeah no but it's still the little drill sword doesn't the character drop that i know it's not elenora
they just dropped it what the fuck i wasn't an invader but they rose from the ground
guys i don't
oh i thought i thought it was a bloody helis that he drops now
the fuck is that noise
the hell
but he came from the ground oh that's so stupid whatever
all right gotta go fucking chat with yura
no not that drill sword i love that drill sword though i remember i for funsies i got that one
it is i just love uh fucking up people's poise with that one i love that sword something
something executioner's blade or whatever uh okay well fuck me then let's just go talk to yura
uh what was that near
it was near markwater cave wasn't it
sanguine noble spawn like that okay
sure
i can't see
all right lukaria bridge
which this one
on which side
no i did get the lantern i have the lantern
see i got the lantern
may an academy gate
north or northeast pass the magic gate and find a summon sign by the bridge see
thank you for giving good fucking directions it's over there no it's that way no
it's that way
go to the left go to no i think it's this one that one
now i gotta drive down to mcdonald's and get some cheeky nuggies oh i want
cheeky nuggies can you guys give me cheeky nuggies can you grab me some cheeky nuggies
in a frosty in a McFlurry wheeze
go to man saturday guys go north northeast north northeast yep
and find a summoning sign by the bridge
okay oh
hmm
hi fia hello little girl come here oh big stretch as i pick you up hi you have a big belly
hi little girl where you going out all right why is every clawing my titties today get your
coochie out of my face you're tangled in my headphones
hello
how are you doing
how are you
did you have a good nap
you come to say hi because i didn't know that stuff wouldn't be more annoying about it
fia has made an appearance
yeah my darling there
no hi nuggies it's funny because i call fia nuggies it might be don't you
get nuggies oh yeah oh good speeches oh good speeches
the deathback of any woke up
keep the top of your head oh she's smiling oh she's smiling remember
fia has made this fia have a quest for us um i'll
need a brush her because she's shedding a lot girl you have a nasty butt why is
it if you guys have nasty butts you just stepped on my keyboard and it sent off a spell
i'm actually impressed
fia do you want to hang out on my lap
there i made room for you come on
he's gonna stay in there and hurt me
if you don't want to be one millennia what's that person that like coded something so they're
like a goldfish could play elden ring or whatever the fuck is that like a fake shit
hi oh are you going are you going
she's like right under my microphone
she's sniffing the microphone she was rubbing against the microphone
fia gets treated differently from boomi because fia isn't a fucking menace to society
she's literally just standing sitting here and purring
i should have already seen this limiting sign uh oh
because i already killed that uh what are you doing with your paws i already killed the guy
she does commit war crimes in the litter oh my god she is nasty she's a stinky girl
she's the cutest stinky girl though
i don't know who you think that's real they also let their goldfish pickpocket
went on role in the goldfish discover a new glitch what that's crazy
no way fia is a femcel fia is a femcel she's stinky she's a stinky neat she likes to game
you're shedding so much oh my god are you rumbling though you're having a good time
sometimes i'll just like wake up and like fias on my chest just purring heavily and i'm just like oh
stinky uh oh stinky why are you rolling sideways in my arms
imagine that's goldfish on summer or sea assist in you
here i'm gonna brush you while you're here
oops sorry just bonks you on the head with the brush
see you're gonna feel nice
you want to sniff you can sniff the brush don't chew the brush
please don't chew my headphones
she's looking at the brush like what the hell unless you're still purring hard
they wish to chew the brush and they wish to chew the headphones
she just turned around and like slowly put her paw on my hand like stop
what's up what'd you hear you're clawing my tit please don't
oh my god i definitely need to put your paws oh my god
was that a helpful squish what was surprising
well no i already i already got that golden seed didn't i
didn't i get the golden seed already i thought i did weird i feel like my save file got messed up
because i feel like i did stuff before or maybe i'm just crazy which is also true
sorry i'm i'm petting my my pussy right now my name is fea giving her brushes
dog beat the ender dragon and minecraft what i need to get fea to play
you think they're brushies you want to sniff oh my god you are shitting so bad
yeah there's a whole other fea i can make
you like the brush though you're you're better at being brushed than boomi is and reina
yeah i'm gonna put the microphone near so you can like hear her pur
i love your hair
she's like really rubbing against the microphone stan
she just licked the microphone what are you doing why are you licking the microphone
why are you licking my windscreen
yeah you like the brushes
you're digging your claws into my chest why
so
now she's chewing on my microphone
booby just came back like what the hell why are you giving fea attention
okay bye
i got two whole bundles of fea first oh my gosh it's so soft wow fea you're so so soft
he's through to the trash and boomi's like what the fuck what did you do to my sister
here do you need help jumping down i can help you all right justice for boomi
what's up big man you look so sad why okay we continue on
need to pull my wedgie again how it's in the front oh there we go
what time is it damn it's almost seven
and i've gotten nothing done how it's what it feels like i did get some stuff done but
i started at 130 and it's almost seven
adam you don't need to do yours quest to get the invader spawn just go to the second
church of america i just did that i was just at the second church of america
i swear to god i already grabbed this golden seed before
that's weird i swear
i am trying to set up stuff i did get the mimic tier
35 percent cat far 45 percent cats north of patches cave
i feel like it did or i almost want to go back in my vault and see if it did that
okay
cleaning on a wall in the cave or what
because i was just at the second church of america
she was not there north of where i fought redubia man well there's two redubia man the one i just
fought and the one before that so go out of the cave so go you gotta give me names go out of
murkwater cave is what i'm assuming that you mean i hate you're a redubia man is in murkwater cave
exit head north thank you
you
already killed or do be a man so i don't know
like it's spookier with the fucking light
what happened to my
exit head north all right
here i'll be waiting outside i will check
okay i don't see you're around
how do you guys hate you're a i'm i need around here is i i really care about them
look like i'm running with gold
oh yeah i don't have to fight him again hey what's up you have the dumbest looking
fucking hat though i actually never have seen his face
yeah i only just joined the fray we didn't fight radon together or anything
that's crazy
okay uh now what
shall we type that kick his ass why do i have to kill him
this is why do i have to i don't have to kill him now he'll be at the academy okay
it is annoying i don't know why he doesn't just talk to you right after you kill
whatever the fucking dude's name is
he literally should just be like thanks for helping me
wait i feel like the moment oh yeah it's the moment you walk past this i feel like it goes oh no okay
all right
i am being summoned into his world
wow i like how like world different worlds are a thing it's kind of weird to me
like there's different like universes and we're all just here
raven mount assassin is he fighting him i don't fucking know oh yeah he is
oh i'm invading
i'll be your backup oh i don't do a lot of damage
oh yes i do
how did you fucking like barely dodge that i want to get the last kill
damn it give me your fucking sword
parallel dimensions make sense since every Elden Ring player even character exists in their
own dimension it's yeah it's so interesting lands in between our literal vibe
ropter of the mists are you gonna fucking oh there you are jesus say something speak up bro are you
dead are you good bro
oh he's tripping yeah it's just me relax bro how do you see through this dumb hat that's
probably why you suck at your job
is it your sword
wow
oh yeah i forgot the lore between him and elenora oh i should girlfriend
my sword's bigger than your sword i'm getting your sword's bigger than mine
uh
i gotta go run over there again uh i'll go this way
i didn't get any um things on the way there
can your dad beat up his dad i think my dad could beat up his dad
um
i need to see
it
damn it i should have jumped on the tree again
thank you
thank you for the many blessings my eye is twitching now
all right let's jump off onto that tree i want to see if it'll work again
what the hell why didn't i just like drift sideways on torrent
take that all right so i ran over here and i kind of like went to that tree it sucks because
there was a um there was a thing that kind of showed me where to jump
i don't think it's there anymore i think i ran over here
fuck off and then i'm gonna jump off this
that's weird um all right now let's not die when i just got here
please oh my god oh
all right
who the fuck are you shooting
no one particular ah there's a cat sniffing my foot who are you is it fia
it was boomy all along i knew it
i'm gonna grab you i got your tail i'm like i'm like i'm here
why you want to get to this box so bad
car jumpscare one hp and torrent um no i know it's fia if it's feet
ah
erm
what torrent's posted he's just like i'm stepping
sorry torrent i'll let you stand upstairs you're not breaking your fucking ankle
little ear flicks he's just he's just happy to be here is he have blood on his muzzle
he's is he's hardcore i don't think he just ate someone
rena don't go rena is sleeping on a chair
she is sleeping on my uh i have little chairs for my countertop because it's a big island
on and so it's just she sleeps on all the chairs
what was i gonna do i was gonna change my outfit please don't match
now they match
oh
harm
oh yeah i'm going to the second church i was like what am i doing
where the fuck i am
anybody ever gets that reference i'll give you a smooch
you
scratching my arm you know her blood moments
all right euro where the fuck are you
you
where the fuck is euro
i'm gonna kill these dogs right now
so i don't have to deal with them later
look on the ground oh is it a call sign i'm looking for all right
is it wait is that it no that's just fucking roses um
where the fuck is
inside the church you right you're probably right
all right guys what the fuck
it trusted you
am i blind you see his body
i didn't finish talking i he said go away i exhausted his dialogue
i did that though
oh my god i'm literally gonna kill this motherfucker
i i think i went to the wrong place but it's fine
i literally
i literally talked to him twice and he's just like
oh
my eye is twitching in irritation
you're uh you're a whore
wait did i go past him again i did he also just blends in with the fucking landscape
oh you son of a bitch
yeah
what
does he that's what he said he's like be be on your way he said this already to me
oh you motherfucker you motherfucker
i already did that though
great where am i where am i going
now i gotta scratch my boob and drive
he looks like a birdie used in badminton
is there something talking about them enforcing him dead in his shirt maybe i should just
fucking kill him myself so you don't have to worry about it
hi
oh
the fuck why are you dead here what happened to you
why are you in my world right now
you
sick um
oh that did nothing to you
oh fuck me oh fire and i said fire
to the right okay i just need to fucking keep doing that essentially
unless she kills me
i hope you can't heal motherfucker
nice turn up your blade oh
no you can't heal
oh oh oh like how she hops back
where the fucking dog come from
oh my god the fucking dog the dog killed me
oh i probably could have killed her first fucking try the dog didn't show up
i really like she beats voice when i'm screaming i'm glad you like it
i'm glad you enjoyed
ah
all right come here come here motherfucker go on come here fucking whore where's the other one
you
miss the first time it's fine all right
aloha mora where are you there you are
why is my locker what
all right i guess i need to be closer oh i love the fucking twin blade though
how are you dodging this shit
how can i get out of the way please
oh sorry
you just let's fight out here how about that can you come out here and we can fight
how
what the hell thank you for letting me heal
you
oh my god
oh but it doesn't matter she can fucking heal too
so
slowly gonna keep spamming this shit get me out of this fucking tree
hold on i need to heal hold on i need healing to do this
oh you fucking cancel me out bitch
so
oh you motherfucker oh you little fucking bitch i'm going to rip out your fucking uterus
serve it up to the fucking place show it on your fucking no you fucking fucking bitch you fucking
cunt
hi
hey
how's it going
sick
so
yeah nice try
okay
if you could play at this fucking game you whore
oh yeah kneel before me suck my fucking metal cock
cute and funny threats instilled fear in me oh sorry
god she's so hot oh when she gets all cute and funny and yells
how many neighbors didn't hear that that'd be awkward uh cool so we got the
we got that he's weak against blood i think i'm kind of sorted
oh i could use the twin blade if i wanted
i do like the twin blade a lot
i need more decks though for that an arcane
i did i did a bleed arcane build before um so i can't exactly use that but i have the
christopher so let's go see vare
yeah i did an arcane faith build and decks build well i mostly like i just got
arcane like i got my decks high enough so i could like wield certain stuff
all right um
should i do mog first or should i do god free
i need more excuse me fuck i didn't mute
i need more sorceries night comet is really good it's fucking sorcery where is night comet again
i don't remember
yeah mog will take longer than god free i'd rather i just like because i'm trying to
i'm also still just level fucking 50 um
so
god free for the talisman
it's below millison okay
the fuck is that noise
is it the fucking dog
okay
back streets back all right
then a chest behind one of the magic walls oh joy wait i should go up here
what the hell
oh i still looked weird
now
oh what a deal i'm on top of the fucking roof all right point me in the direction
what is that over there just a sparkly dude
and we're going for new magics uh i have a fucking arrow in my side i'm good now
i need to light the things
i mean wait for the first left comet i never um yeah i never completed because again i never
did any sorcery stuff so i never completed that okay i need to light each one
so one two three is it just three or am i missing one is there a fourth one next to me
only three all right let's do it let's fucking ball uh let's do it let me go to this one first
let's go to the snake america i just want to see where it drops me
let's fucking ball just get shit on um actually let me go grab my runes
that was funny
i had a feeling i was gonna die when i jumped off and i'm like yeah it's for the bit
it's for the bit it's up there
where did it where did they go where'd my runes go oh yeah right there okay
oh my god oh my god please oh my god please for it for the love of christ i'm begging you
not that that does anything really um
torrent don't kill me torrent torrent for the love of god torrent please
all right let's fucking do this thing okay
how do i get up there
do i need torrent to get up there
oh okay don't fall back down now
let's ball here's add an explosion
i'll see it was broken in town somewhere all right uh let's go to that one because it's the closest
can i get down it's like you cannot send unless you interacted this
let's see if i can just use torrent to cheese oh no i can't for some of them here
about perfect uh it's legs oh my god this poor animal
okay fine
thank you
so
where are you digging in there for
okay get up there
hello
so
thanks
i can't i jump up
oh torrent move what are you doing bro he just stopped
i got the cast so fast oh there's two of them that's why
uh let me just
i'm gonna die
oh
come on torrent how the fuck do i get back up
so
oh hello let's get there
oh my god everybody's like invisible um
so like you said what the hell
all right finally i'm up
what the fuck is that dude over there the hell
uh
are you just playing with shit what are you doing bro
yeah yeah i hear you behind me i'm not interested
i hate invisible old bed he's really invested in a rubik's cube looks like he was like playing with
something
all right look at this guy he's just like i'm waiting come and down here
come on
what are you doing
how do you have any health left
you're good bro come back up come on you can do it i believe in you come on
he's having a tough day
okay my range doesn't get all the way over there what is this oh he all right uh torrent
don't fuck this up for me now
oh he almost fucked it up for me
oh torrent please all right looks like i'm doing this one on foot
i'm a platformer maybe let me upgrade a part of my
pain and introduce it into the famous upgrade
all right where is this fucking thing am i supposed to see it off the rip
no
it's in a hidden wall in town but where
look for chests around tour it opens a door barrier in the ground level part of the north part of
town let's try it
no i wanted to you know keep a bird's eye view but it is what it is um
sorry i'm busy sorry i got stuff to do
oh how convenient
oh that's nice actually
a yank oh hold on oh god oh i didn't i didn't want to be in this type of gangbang
uh all right
all right
what's over here what's this then
ow ow ow can you stop i'm doing shit i like that spell though oh fuck
invisible old men ow can i fuck off
why are you a ghost and you're hurting me i don't
oh i'm like where is it coming from
oh
fuck off oh you're hitting me with books can i just have this please
all right there we go anybody else anybody fucking else oh you come on over
yeah hopefully you just lock on that that's fine
ah that's not what i wanted
i didn't mean to do that but you know what fucking get them dogs uh that's cool
i meant to summon torrent but this is also fine
oh
i'm sorry whatever you're selling i'm not buying
wait i think i saw something over there
hello old puppies
oh
oh my god people are pointing at this door
you don't have to put right ahead is it a is it a thingy no all right
what's down here what no way
i'm not doing melissin's quest i'm getting done night comet
uh i passed it i fucking won't is there a painting over here what are you doing
i miss it's fine
everybody die what
it's weird uh
sorry sorry to bump you sir i'm um busy i need to i have places to be i passed it it must be over here then
guys i'm gonna make a freaking lose it
i'm gonna stand right here tell me where to go
okay
east okay so i go straight ahead north that way oh you guys are so helpful thank you
what would i do without you guys truly uh i love them do anything that doesn't do anything
i'm just passing a lot of stuff oh what's this nope i was already over here fucking hell
oh
can you chill bro damn you are casting so fast
east to west from where i was
um
getting a fucking headache going in circles
what is this guy doing is this gonna reach me i better not
do
i hear shit
uh that's just a sparkly thing
on top of the roof i think
now i'm just at the swamp of aonia hello
oh it was very nice to you it was a very cash money of you how
climb you fool climb torrent climb
all right i'm up here now
i have baby have a good one
guys i don't know where the shit is oh i'm gonna die oh i did die
oh Jesus fuck
somebody shoot me unless somebody stopped me but you guys get to do
all right i'm gonna go rest the side of grace
a lot of the little whoop pardon me gentlemen
oh stop by the shack by the southern gate
wait actually
stop by the shack at the southern gate
stop by the shack stop whispering what shack i don't see a fucking shack
we're getting night comet
i think this is just referencing that shack yeah i don't really care about that that's
that has to do with medicine
should be that actually i haven't really been towards the northern part of the town so let me
actually go in that direction
but i keep it a stack
yeah there's dudes over here oh fuck i'm in a corner um sorry a part of me i'm so sorry to interrupt
to me torrent
fuck to me torrent oh what's that over there is that anything
no
all right let's just chill here for a second i will look at a video
wait what's the other there
wait a second
damn it i thought this was a door
fuck
please from grace seek east to the north no
that won't stop me because i go where the fuck did you come from
Jesus
where's my stop don't mad at me
pulling
i'm gonna mute my audio for a second
okay
joe hammer
why do you have a random witch lady on the side
all right yeah yeah yeah just tell me where it is bro
yep yep you lit all the flames
you
what the fuck how do i pass that shit i don't understand
that's so weird
literally whatever this is
got the staff of loss which is cool
oh damn it uh it's a little eerily right here
yeah and i call it anyways get the fuck out of here
ah you just fucking bitch slapped me stop i'm young and i'm fresh and i'm plumping i don't deserve to die
i don't deserve this oh
ah i'm fine
huh i'm fine i can't use it
i need 38 intelligence
oh
i believe so
the wool wheeled staves i want to have
i still don't actually i thought i was at like 30 but i wrote
that
it's time for the rune farm ladies and gentlemen let's go everybody let's go where the fuck is
varre i'm gonna make him sorry where are we going clap clap clap
i always forget where we start off
finally some content you want to fight bro
where did this motherfucker go oh yeah the word rose church that's right um
can i can i kill the knight
let's see if i can
so
oh i didn't think you could hit me
fuck
you get off the way yeah bro
oh now you know how to block shit now that's nice
so
fucking now bro
oh how'd that mess here
you gonna put your shield up
i have to be like facing you
uh
at this point
damn it um i was gonna say at this point i'm just gonna fight him on foot
whatever mind
yeah i don't know how i didn't stagger him
i'm using a shield that's
let's kill this motherfucker
let's check out where the fuck is he
oh
fuck
okay but go off
so you got the horse in the head oh actually let me pop this for the bad player real quick
oh
can i please like hit you i'm out of the fucking shit uh
uh
that didn't really make much difference
okay bye torrent
oh i forgot i have the wrong thing equipped
so
oh
oh you're fucking little horsey
how are you not fucking staggered
i fucking rolled out i rolled i pressed b
oh i also pressed b there
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
why i'm pressing the wrong button
oh my god what the fuck why is my hitbox hard
excuse me excuse me
what was that then
what
can you die can you literally just fucking kill yourself i mean
uh i mean an elden ring of course
oh thank god
god
whoa oh i'm sorry i just wanted to kill him
gamer sheebie
what do you mean jesus
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
i need to take something from my head hi toma
oh
all right
are you speaking of me
heard that that was his name
bring another snappy
one
well i see it's supposed to
Are you alive? Okay. Just check me. Just check me. Hi. Oh, did you hear that?
Go show me the work. I don't know.
Let's see.
I'll call a bit and I can change this.
Oh, wait. This isn't for you. Go away.
Stop. No. Don't be. Why are you trying to take me so much today?
Turn around and move easy. You might not be able to see me. Let's put it in the microwave.
Don't start jumping in the microwave.
Boomi is here.
Well, he wants to pull him out of Boomi. First, she be steals Boomi chicken noodles soup.
Now, his mac and cheese.
Oh, he does. He climbs in the cabinets. He climbs in the fridge. He climbs in my washing machine.
He tries to get into the dryer, but it's stacked on top of the washing machine so you can't get to it.
He tries to get into the microwave. I think he's talking to the microwave once.
He's got a dishwasher where I was loading it up and I walked away for a moment.
He literally has, I have to double check that he's not somewhere so I don't accidentally fucking kill him.
I'm just going to feed up. I have a little next-level thing that you can feed it up and it has essential oils and stuff.
So it's kind of like a relaxive... relaxive.
I'm going to put a little bit of barbecue sauce on my mac and cheese and a little barbecue sauce.
And you know, thankfully I have barbecue sauce because I only accommodate it to my home.
It's Chick-fil-A barbecue sauce.
I'm going to put a little balsamic on it, you know, a little bit of balsamic.
Oh, delicious.
He's talking me into buying groceries.
Mmm, girl dinner. It's just what? It's just mac and cheese and a little bit of barbecue sauce on my phone.
Very tasty.
He's trying to bake it in the bottom.
Oh, my God.
My diet is condiments? No.
It's very sacred to have girl dinner. Very sacred.
It's very good girl dinner.
You need real food that's not DoorDash? Yeah, so...
I'm not sure if it's a Bible study.
Girl dinner is essential.
Yeah, Toma gets it.
Toma has amazing girl dinners, so like she'll post her for girl dinners of the day for girl breakfast.
Precisely. I'll be able to get some home cooked meals.
It's funny because like I can cook, like I'm a good cook and all I just don't have any rest like materials to cook with.
Oopsies.
Oh, hey, my audio comes out today.
Where do I get Azur's comment?
My eye itches.
I'll have to do Selen's quest. Is it worth it?
Because I feel like, because that doesn't like stomach him. That'll be a while.
No? Okay.
What are your suggestions? Do you think I should really just like aim just to do bleed?
Because I remember last time I beat Mogue, I literally, I just summoned somebody and they literally just whipped out Azur's comment and just fucking mowed him down.
And I was like, oh, thanks, Rando. Because again, yeah, he's very slow.
Yeah, give me, give me some just because I still have one slot.
I have a slot, a memory slot. I'm cracking it back.
Ah, there it is. Ah, there it is again.
That's if you're overleveled from him.
No, I try to like be bosses by myself in the night. If I can't do it, then I'll summon you guys.
There's no suit with dead. I just teared and commented him too, but you need to be quite leveled. Okay.
Nice crack. I'll look at my butt. I'm kidding. I'm looking at my boobs. I'm kidding.
I'm getting a really bad pain in my lower back. I feel like I need to like stand up.
I'm going to put my pants down so I can lift this heat on my back. Oh, that feels so good.
Ah, my back hurts too.
Sorry, again, I'm a 52 year old woman. Sorry, 56 year old woman.
So it's very hard to live.
I'm getting dialysis on my ass.
Sorry.
And the breasts are out of strength on the screen. How's that?
Good. Torture y'all.
Tell me, did you just steal her spring? Are you bringing it to me? Do you want me to throw it? Okay, drop it.
Oh, thank you.
Ready?
We're getting it.
Brother, did you get it? Okay, bring it back. Bring it back.
Nope, bring it back. Boomie.
You dropped it too far. Don't look at me. I'm not grabbing it.
He's like looking at me like, why don't you come and pick it up and throw it again, please?
Yeah, don't knock it under the closet door.
This feels nice on my back.
This is only 26.
I know it requires a lot, but we're literally about to start farming.
I'm probably going to go get some arrows so I can farm that bird.
A question, though. Did they patch the farm where you're still where Mogwin's Castle is?
And you kind of like go through these rocks and you go through this cave and then you jump down and then you just swing and dagger back and forth and then you just farm?
Did they patch that? Did you just fall through the map?
Did the bird farm still work? Okay.
I remember doing that, you know, farm for a bit because you got more, I believe, in the bird farm.
All right.
Oh, Toma just went live.
What is it called? She goes off?
There it is, also, live because it's age.
Toma, I know where it is.
I need a heart.
You!
Yeah, I think I'll go through these.
Okay, hi. Sorry.
I got distracted because I don't know what to do with you.
It's funny.
I don't know if you're okay with me bringing it back, but I'm just sitting here.
I really wish I had ice cream.
Did I already talk about ice cream today? Do I now want ice cream?
I'm not going to be my appetite screen back all the time.
How are you guys doing? Are you guys okay?
He's falling asleep from the dead silence and then he's like, hey guys.
You get an EP?
You could have gotten an ice cream when you buy groceries.
I'm a bit EP too.
I can't believe I've been streaming for almost eight hours.
Oh.
Look, there's also makeup.
Okay.
You don't need it.
Okay, okay.
Hi.
Sorry, am I leaving?
I've been sitting down for a real long time.
Hello.
Being back.
Super EP.
12.15. Time for sleep.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. Good night everybody that's going to sleep.
Good night.
Sleep tight.
Don't let the madam bite.
Because I will and he'll be very, very hard.
I'm working while the stream is on.
I don't know why this is so scary.
Proof.
Watch that voice. This is top scare.
Pro controversial madam.
Bye everybody. Have a good night.
Thank you for stopping by.
If you guys got stuff to do, make sure you go do it.
If you have chores to do, make sure you.
public. Did your, did your peepee jump? Did your bible jump up in joy? Sorry, that's
my, um, hair leaning back in it. Giving yourself the ol' hawk to look? My house? Nice, nice.
8-18 for me. Good for another 4-6 hours. Uh, no, I'm gonna just keep playing.
Talk to my brother like that. Man, like, leg needs to pop and I can't pop it.
Okay, pop it.
Selling your torch yesterday or should I be a mistake? Did I miss your left or dead club?
That was good. That was a really fun collab.
Make sure you watch the void.
I say my bible says so, do you say that? Hee hee hee. Hee hee hee, hoo hoo hoo.
Alright, where am I?
Look, I'm at my pillow, at my blinky.
Let me fix my model. I haven't looked at OBS this entire time, so I, I apologize if my
model's like, far the fuck away.
Okay, um, let me grab that. Let me do that.
Lean back.
Make myself a little bit bigger.
I'm close. By my clouds.
Should we talk for over 4 hours after? Yeah, I know, it's not the same.
Danielson says, I know, they fucking took out Azura, like, what the hell?
Yeah, I was, I was surprised I kept talking, because I literally was gonna end stream right after
the collab and like, go like, fuck about or whatever. And then, um, what was it?
Then Azura's like, oh, I think I might talk to my chat and like say bye and everything.
I'm like, oh, actually, I should do that too.
And talk to you guys about, like, that I'll be leaving for a little bit.
Um, and then I just talk for 4 hours.
Lipsies.
Oopsie-doopsies.
Aw, I hope you feel better.
I'm sorry I'm in pain too.
I almost paid, I know, you guys almost got me to talk another 30 minutes.
It's not happening again, I still want to watch a boys episode.
Oh la la la la la.
How long have I been streaming for?
Let's see.
I just feel like it's been more than 8 hours.
Um, goes by, would you have a phone?
Oh wait, now I can see the chat.
I do love the app streams.
I love the app in two guys.
Instructions.
You have that effect.
Ow, my knee.
Uh, I just hit my knee.
The app love.
Live, live the app love.
That was a beautiful shot you guys were able to see.
Just people just like hanging out, you know, just chilling.
I always love the compare, like the similarities between this and like Christ on the cross.
And then it's like Merica, because Merica is like Christ essentially and God.
It's very interesting to me, the parallels, the biblical stuff in this game.
What's my runes?
What the hell?
Can I pick them up please? Jesus Christ.
What am I doing now?
Cool.
Oh yeah, I'm going to West of Gaitown.
Over here, isn't it?
I don't know why I closed it out.
I kind of felt Christian fiction is a Jesus thing and not just a cruel way to kill people invented by the Romans.
Well it was, like if Jesus was the only one that was crucified, they would do that to just normal people.
It's really funny because it's like, I think they discovered they never put them on crosses,
but it was just like a giant stake in the ground where you're pinned up above your head and below your legs.
The south of the marker?
Below this?
I think you're right.
Yeah, the random dude who's just like, I'm hanging out.
He's just like, ah, you'll be with me in heaven in paradise.
Although, again, different translations.
Sorry, excuse me.
Oh yes, the temple fortah.
Yeah, that's a lot.
Oh, fuck that I got all over here.
I need to get a better vantage point.
Alright.
Let's go.
Damn, that horse can jump.
Yeah, I remember I grew up reading the King James version of the Bible.
You want to go to the next island to the south on the map?
Over there?
That one?
That's not the south, is it?
That's the west.
Over there?
I think that's it straight ahead.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me go get my fucking...
That was weird, where are they?
Thank you.
That was odd.
Oh, no ice.
I died there, but you know, go off, sis, I suppose.
I guess I won't go down that particular way, because it just killed me.
So just step out right here and land properly.
Right here, and land properly.
Sorry if you can hear Fiamme yelling to herself in the background, she's playing.
Bari, where the fuck are you, bro?
There you are.
You are...
You look like a woman.
You look like a very comely woman.
What's up with that?
Thank you.
Did I sneeze again?
I don't remember.
They didn't seem right.
They look gross and sickly.
We come through the maid in himself.
Why are you covered in blood?
Fari's the baddest.
Baddest of them all.
Ooh, you wanna dance, baby?
Oh.
It's had a really bad burp.
I wonder what happens if, like, you say, I think they're awesome.
Wow.
All right.
I don't really feel like I'm meeting a random person.
Um...
I forget how do you do this without...
I rather do the P-W-E. I'm online, so if I go...
Okay.
I don't know why I'm here.
Ah, I'm stuck.
I don't know why I clicked that.
I just saw an accept button, and I wanted to click it.
Um...
Okay.
I don't know why I clicked that.
I just saw an accept button, and I wanted to click it.
Um...
Yeah, don't you have to be in offline mode?
Uh, let's do it.
Oh, I didn't mean to fucking press that.
It's fine.
What?
I'm offline.
Is it working?
I forgot to inform you we're still alive.
Shit.
What do you mean?
First Mount Gelmer Bridge Grace?
Press any button.
Continue.
You don't have to be offline, though.
I've beaten it offline.
Because you just fight the random NPCs.
The fuck off.
I was running in the wrong direction.
Hi!
What?
But I've done it without invading someone before.
Why isn't it letting me do it?
There's an NPC I could just kill in the white blood ruins.
That's an...
You said the Altus Watto?
Okay.
White blood ruins.
My eyes fucking twitching.
Quick! Google search!
It's writhed blood, by the way.
It's not white blood.
Why are they so small?
Better do it than she being Google.
Me and you.
Who made you do this?
You're spreading under the couch.
I think you just did.
Ooh, what this blood grease?
Spring or cry?
I literally just got them four springs
from out from under my...
They? Fire monks?
No.
Out from under...
my fridge, so...
Alright.
Where are you at?
Fucking dogs.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm s- I have them in the wrong thing.
Oh, no.
Hold on.
I forgot I had them in the wrong...
May what?
Oh, no. What the fuck?
I was confused.
Should be an invasion sign?
Oh, okay.
I thought I did this all before.
I just don't fucking remember shit.
Hmm.
What are you eating in that one?
Fucking dogs!
Oh, you fucking puppy!
Flashes.
Actually, I'm gonna kill these fucking dogs
before I do anything.
Oh, what the hell?
I'm gonna kill them all
because it did the little indication that I did.
Anyone else?
Alright.
I should fold this guy.
He is running at me.
Jesus.
Yeah, I fucking understand.
Oh, God.
Jesus, stop using beast magic on me.
Oh, I didn't mean to hit that.
Oh, let's not die.
Oh, I forgot you only have limited shit.
I totally forgot about that.
I totally forgot about this thing.
Sorry, bro.
You can revert the eyes
in the mirror in the wrong table.
What?
The other, the bloody finger quest
gives you character weird eyes.
Oh!
You've ruined your fashion souls, Bill.
That's funny.
I forgot.
Yeah, they get like, I left them
because I thought they looked cool.
Shibu Pro Gamer?
I don't know about that.
Yeah, it makes your eyes fucking weird looking.
I liked it, though, because my character had
really pale gray skin and platinum white hair.
So it was cool.
Yeah, I'm happy I killed them
because then they can't just fucking attack me
when I'm standing here.
It makes you a star.
So, yeah, I like the frenzy frame.
It makes your eyes like crazy gold,
orangey shit, and I always like that.
Who was talking?
I don't know.
I hear someone like deeply breathing.
What the fuck is that?
Become a witcher.
The ucky burn marks aren't a good point.
Sorry, I'll stop breathing.
What is your name?
Oh, you have a dog nearby?
I don't think that's what dogs sound like.
It sounds like there's a troll below me
laughing.
Oh, it is like dogs.
What the fuck are those?
Oh, it's like the Blight dogs.
That's terrifying.
I'm like, what the hell is that noise?
The worm face, bros.
Alright, where's the next one?
Point me in the right direction.
I'll fuck him up.
I'll blow him up.
Uh oh.
It's like that slog that goes
really like 10 miles an hour
or whatever the heck
towards your location.
But you never know when it's coming
and it's just one of those fucking things.
They might want the Patreon link.
Patreon link is in the description below, guys.
Oh, check out my new audio. It's coming out tonight.
I'll figure out which one it is.
Wait, hold on. I'll tell you right now.
The inevitable snail, precisely.
I don't know.
I don't know, because like it
management puts it up or like
strongly schedules it, so I don't
know exactly.
Put her down?
Okay, it's supposed to start loading right now.
I thought it was suspended for a second.
I was like, yay.
Oh.
Okay.
There is a schedule.
What day is it?
What weekend is it?
GFTSU, their impressive milk collection.
GFTSU is actually into
awesome female superiors,
but it sounds like that makes me feel good.
I'm strawing the techie behind the girls.
Uh, yeah.
Sure.
Wait, guys.
Where's the next one?
I feel like I'm just replaying the game at a faster speed.
Except I'm not
faster.
Am I done?
I have to go top bar, right?
I thought I had to kill more than one.
I thought I had to kill three.
It gave me away those fucking worm things.
He just really wanted me to kill that one guy.
I thought I had to kill that one guy.
I thought I had to get some bloody maiden shit.
I have to go back to
that church
and then dip it in the maiden's blood, probably.
Where am I going?
Okay, wrong way.
That's where I'm going.
I don't have
any sense of
direction.
That's the next step? Okay.
Blood lady.
You're fun to watch. Good luck in the DLC.
Aw, thank you. Appreciate it.
I'm just a goofy little goobah.
Oh, it's your first super on a live stream.
I popped you a super cherry.
Thank you. Thank you.
Hey, Leos.
Hellos. Hellos.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Yeah.
Hello.
Vore.
I have to speak with you. There's a weird guy.
Hi.
Is this the guy I gotta come get me?
It's so nice. Thank you.
I wonder what he looks like
without his mask on.
Why are you rubbing your hands together like that?
Aw, thank you.
Yeah, I'm totally not going to kill your god.
Dynasty.
Because he likes Micola.
He likes little...
Yeah.
Who would have a...
I mean, I can't say that.
I thought I'd get...
How'd I get the...
Okay.
Ermm.
Yeah, it broke a long time ago.
I don't know why he's breaking lately.
Oh, it broke.
Damn, it does not want to work.
Usually, I can just refresh the...
source.
Does my stream die?
I think I'm fine, aren't I?
Did my stream die?
Yeah, this is where I just want to work.
Oh, there we go.
Back here.
Yeah.
I'm trying to fix it.
Yeah, this looks gross.
I have to make it look like it was before.
Because I always have to generate a link.
I'll put it in Comic Sans.
Okay, looks a little bit wonky.
It's funny, because it works.
It sounds like I'm talking into a fan.
Why does it sound like I'm talking into a fan?
What the fuck?
It's still not working.
It does not want to work.
Okay.
It's like very delayed.
That's so weird.
I wonder why it's doing that.
And even if there was a fan,
y'all spilling eyelash,
why is the microphone...
Did it actually bump my...
weird?
Oh, it was when I was really distant.
Oh, it was because I was
when I lay down here.
Yeah.
I sound fine.
Oh, that's nice.
Why did nobody tell me
that since I played the video
to find where something was
needed?
Why didn't anybody tell me
that I didn't turn my desktop audio
back on?
What's wrong with you?
Because I may be.
I was scared.
Oh.
Because my voice is cute.
You could hear Vari, though?
What?
What the fuck is going on in my game sound, then?
Because it was literally
I had like...
I had set it as off.
That's weird.
Why did I still have audio then?
Oh, maybe it was like...
I don't know. I give up.
I don't care that much.
It's a show that was muted for me
on OBS.
Okay.
I don't think I'm going to be able to make chat work.
Oh.
Now it works.
I don't know why that works,
although I just kept refreshing it
over and over and over again.
My first jinx.
My toes are cold. Come suck on them.
He doesn't know that I have a maiden.
Alright, let's go to...
Where was it?
Er...
Backstreet's back.
Alright.
Can I just fucking...
Do you want to get from Missle?
Missle? Where was that?
It was in Caled, wasn't it?
That was near the Frenzy Village.
Wasn't that up here?
I'm like, where was it?
Was it the Second Church of America?
Was it the Ernie?
Oh yeah, you're right.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
The Church of inhibition?
I kind of remember...
I always... I always...
I keep confusing the Church of inhibition
where the church is, where the turtle is at.
That's why.
I don't know why I keep thinking the turtle is here.
Thank you.
It is...
I wish my eye would stop twitching.
Thanks for watching.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Okay.
I'm going to...
I'm surprised I accidentally ran into the little pillar that has what's-her-face on it.
It was like, I'm secretly a salamander person thing area, which is another name I almost
called Fia, but I'm like, I don't... I didn't like her that much. What's happening here?
That guy doesn't have a head. Oh, what? What's happening? Oh, stop it. I don't like that I
can get aggroed right over here. That was just really funny. I just, I always wanted to see if there
was a pillow. I need another pillow. Put my arm on. I'm bothered. I didn't even know
there's a fucking stake America here. Uh, yoink. Okay, do I have enough to level up? I need 16.
Oh, I can get 16. I can get 16. I wish I selected two, but it's fine. Oh, damn it. I didn't mean to talk to you.
Luminary Moog!
Are you gonna cut off my finger when I do something for this?
Sorry, hold on a moment.
This looks so funny because he's not really doing anything.
Luminary Moog! Off her finger.
I thought he was gonna say cream. I always be like, yeah, you know, I got some sweet cream.
If you do, I do say so myself. Let me go to here for a second.
This is a little nasty.
All right.
What am I doing? Oh, it's my cat's food.
Are you kidding me? I need like 50 runes.
It's freedom time. I'm gonna turn the lights like a fuck suit.
All he has in question, when he's coming out from somewhere, he was like, oh, and then
Raina's still napping. Raina, go eat.
Do you accept cat food by any chance?
Did he not give me the badge yet? What do you mean the badge?
Yeah.
I mean the badge.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Maybe I need to talk to him again. Maybe I didn't exhaust my...
That's right. It's the badge. I don't know why I thought it was the bloody finger.
I probably didn't exhaust the dialogue.
All right. I don't have a badge.
Wow.
Oh, that's so crazy. Wow. Wow. Wow.
He's in front of me. You must wait. I'm there. All right. Let's see if I can remember.
Let's see if I can remember how to get there.
It's because I had been sitting there for hours and hours.
Pardon me. You guys look like you're doing well. Really nice. So happy for you. Oh, thank you.
Sorry. Pardon me.
He has a slug.
I don't know what you guys are worshipping, but good for you.
That was a big boy.
Existing. You're just on the walking tip.
That's there.
I never get what's down here. Oh, yeah, that's right. More sanguine dudes.
Oh, hey. What are you doing up here? No.
Who will what this?
No.
Fucking hell. Oh, no.
Yeah, I got the mimic.
And like, it's not going to even teleport me at the grace. Yeah, okay, I gotta go back because
it's annoying.
Can you?
Like, oh, it didn't let me spawn at the church America.
So happy I got a lantern before this.
Why is he so fucking fast for no reason?
Oh, please.
I just want to be like, oh my god. What's this?
I need to be over here.
What the fuck is this guy?
What is this?
I'm in the wrong spot. Sorry.
Hold on. My ear is itchy.
Oh, I don't want to do mob. I'm trying to get to the fucking... ow.
I'm going to kill me with the time I get over there.
Oh, I went the wrong way. I'm like, this doesn't look familiar.
Yeah, yeah, I'm trying to remember where it is.
You know, that's where I came from. Why is this guy still aggroing me?
You can't see me. I know, I need to go over here.
Oh, it's fucking this way. Oh, I forgot. I know where it is.
I forgot it's in the opposite direction.
Nope, I'm in the wrong spot again.
I'm in the wrong spot again. Yeah, because that's it.
Oh, yeah, because this is where you get invaded by the fucking white masks.
Oh, that's fucking...
That's right.
Oh, I can't use it until I... where am I going? I can drop it this way, it's fine.
I remember getting there.
Oh, I can't pick it up.
Because you avoid the little skeletors.
Yeah, go over here.
I remember seeing them and being like absolutely terrified.
I forget which way you go. It's not this way, because that's where you get raided.
Then you cut through over here.
Oh, that's a lie.
Yeah.
Over here, yeah, that's right.
Let's go! Where the fuck did the dudes all go?
Oh, they're on this down this way, I forgot.
I'm surprised I'm actually doing okay at level 50. I'm not going to lie to you.
Before I... I just wanted to grab this first, and I don't really care about my runes.
And then I want...
So, we heard that it's underground.
I want to go to the round table.
Oh, wrong way. I thought I almost had it.
D, you destroyed. Fuck. D, it's your fault.
I'm happy I didn't do that anyways. I don't have any fucking glove word.
I wish I could buy glove word.
You need to grind to level 140-ish? Yeah.
I can't believe you doubted me. How could you, me, of all people?
Well, I guess this is where we yapp together. This is the yapping portion of the stream where I grind stuff out.
I don't have an eighth. I mean a seventh. God damn it. I thought I had a seven. That doesn't matter.
I need to hurry. I need to hurry.
Yeah, I don't know why they allow the Dung Eater just to hang out.
Like he's like literally generally horrible.
How do I use the Mimic?
He isn't technically there. That's true, but still.
Yapping portion of the can at once. The love sum. Come, Eater.
Oh, did I roll into something over here?
I remember someone like bowed. I remember seeing someone just like gesture,
like email in front of the fucking armor. I think that was so funny. That was always funny to me.
I don't know how people email when they leave a message. I never figured that out.
Okay, if it's done, you don't have to worry about plumbing.
I should probably buy some arrows.
Oh, I have just like random shit.
I need strength.
That's so stupid.
Still have a heavy load.
Yeah, okay, I'm wearing PJs.
Sore seal in two hands. You're probably right. Yeah, that's a good idea.
I don't, I don't know if that'll do it though.
Does the sore seal give you five?
Yeah, it won't be enough.
Godric room. Yeah, I got that.
If I do that and I pop that, well, it's not like I don't need to use it appropriately.
I just need people to just shoot it.
Okay.
Why can I, can I not dual wield?
Yeah, let's do right that then.
Can't do it in, oh, that makes sense.
I'm like, where is it?
I'm just stupid. I'm just gonna do this to make my life easier.
What the fuck was that?
Left bumper aim. Oh, that's right.
Fuck, I miss.
Oh my god.
Yep, this will be fun. I should probably go buy arrows.
What a dummy.
You're the gold. Fuck, I don't want the gold scarab because I'm like, wait, usually you get more than
this. Oh, where's the gold scarab?
Where's the gold scarab?
How am I going to eat me?
In a dungeon in Caled. Oh, brother, it's, it's, it,
is it that one? It's that one, right?
Pretty sure it's this one.
Behind the dual, yeah, it's by the crystal bitches.
We're doing this first before I get the fourth talisman slot.
I'm gonna have to cut across to get on the other side here.
I may not fucking kill myself.
It's over there. It's on the other side.
I don't have the dragon barrow. Oh, this one. That's a smoldering wall.
What? Isn't the dragon barrow one? That's the great bridge.
I think I can make this jump.
Well, I definitely can't make the jump.
I wish I could just go over here and just like loop up and around. That just makes my life a lot easier.
Yeah, you can raise it just a lot closer.
Okay, let's do this first, just so I don't freaking kill myself for all.
Let's put this bad boy away. She's, she's a little bit big.
How's it hanging? That's going pretty good. I'm starting to go nonverbal because I'm EP.
No, not like this.
Let's not go live instead.
Ha ha.
He's staring at nonverbal, madam.
Did I wake you up?
No, wait, I meant to go to the last
Christ visiting because it's just gonna teleport me down there. Sometimes I'd purposely throw
myself off a cliff to get to a like a steak America. Yeah, because now I'm fucking down here.
Wake me up. Wake me up. So save me.
Come on.
Madam, madam's thing is pretty. I don't know what you're talking about. Oh, what's a fucking
bed doll? Oh, that's a fucking sleepy lady. Where am I going? Where did you come from?
Where did you go? Where did you come from? Oh my god. Where are you?
I just lost 11,000 runes, bro.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I remember distinctly this happening before too when I was going
to this part.
Hi, Boomi. How can I help you handsome boy?
Are they a bird up here? No.
How did I not aggro the thing before? I don't get that.
All right, let's just walk. How about that? Let's just walk. Oh my god, Boomi.
Oh, oh my kitty. No, please. Why do you walk on my boob? You're still standing on my boobs.
Oh my god. Stop. Go away.
Why have you done this to me? What are you doing? I'm going to hold you like a baby.
Now you're stuck with me like this in baby mode. No, don't leave me. You can't leave now.
You're in baby mode. You have to be held like a little baby.
And I can give you scratches. Why are you so heavy? You're like this feels like your way as much as a toddler.
Why are you so big? Why did you become like that? Why are you looking at me?
Why won't you make eye contact with me?
He's like leaning away like mother, please. There you go.
Let's look into the snack box and see what we got. Shall we, Boomi?
Oh, don't attack my headphones.
Where's this? Like a little biscuit. It is called Delos and it is cappuccino flavored.
Boomi in baby mode. Yeah, Boomi in baby mode is literally just like holding him like he's the
baby and it's like he's on his back as the leggies are sticking out.
Marina and Boomi are just sniffing each other.
Marina, you look like you're about to hop up here.
Yeah, cappuccino.
How can this happen to me and me? I'm rubbing my eyes.
I'm fading. No, Marina, you're in the way.
Shut up. I don't need your sass. I didn't mean to press that.
Marina, get out. All I see is cat butt and a tail. Oh my god.
Marina just kicked the microphone.
Why are you flicking your tail? She's mad because I put her on the ground.
She's like, what the fuck?
All right.
Berry carefully.
Berry carefully. Jump. You made it.
Oh, good luck. I'm sure you're, I don't have to wish you luck because I'm sure you'll pass.
You don't need any luck. You got this.
A different moment from switching rooms. How is she? I'm fine. I'm here. I'm in the abandoned cave.
Feeling abandoned.
Okay, I'm just going to run to the boss room. I think I remember where the boss room is.
I remember doing the whole farm thing. It was more of the more recent things I had done in the game.
All right. Nothing I need to do that. Oh, fuck. I need, I need, I forgot. I need bloodhound step.
Oh, that's not the right one. Damn it.
I forgot.
I forgot that usually I would use just bloodhound step with this.
Is it shub over? Just a little bit.
I thought the staunching bowl was this for the right ones. Oh, this is going to be annoying.
I'm not going to go all the way to do that.
To do that, get that ash of war.
Yeah, digrow the quick step. No. That's what I meant. I'm sorry.
I thought I had the right boluses. I forgot. I had actually prepared for this. I didn't just jump in.
Oh, no. We totally have the fungus armor. What are you talking about?
I also don't have any fucking boluses.
I don't have any fucking cookbooks.
I suppose we're going to do a quick store run
to Caled. Oh, I can't leave.
At least I got the grace to care about.
It's funny that you can teleport from like, whatchamacallit.
Sounded like something was leaking in my bathroom. Ever get what I was saying?
No, I haven't been buying cookbooks. I've just been, I haven't been doing anything.
Hi.
Okay, so I can get those from you.
Oh, it's like I have to do so much shit in order to prepare for the fucking DLC.
I should have just played through the game again.
I was kidding. It'd be like a hundred hours.
You want me to butterfly?
Why did I do that? I didn't mean to press that. I meant to press that way.
Where do you, I have Reduvia, so I do have a dagger.
Oh fuck, but I can't put it on that.
Jody Daggers.
You don't, you're useless to me.
It's a journey and that's okay. I just like, I just, that's why I was always, I didn't know
whether or not I wanted to replay Elden Ring just because I'd have to do all this shit.
But I'm glad. I'm actually having lots of fun spending time with you guys.
I went the wrong way.
I know I did it, I'm fine.
Okay, Lude.
This is more yapping time. Yeah, but I want to get play the DLC guys.
You also don't have a dagger.
I like how this negates fire, but this is, this is funny.
I could get this for my outfit.
Bye-bye.
Lady from Round Table Shirtle Dagger, you're right.
What am I doing?
I placed that little cookie thing down somewhere and I don't know where it went.
I like never ate it. I just placed it on the ground, or not on the ground. Did I put it back
in the box? I swear I took it out. I have no idea where it went. I like put it somewhere.
Oh, it was next to me. It's like right next to my butt.
I'm like, I wanted to try this cappuccino cookie. Oh, it smells so good.
I wish I had coffee to make to eat this with it. Wait, I do have coffee to make to eat this with it.
Should I? Should I?
Should I make some coffee?
Hmm.
Let me not do this. Let me not drink coffee
at 10 p.m. because then I won't be able to sleep.
Am I going the right way?
I don't have any fucking money. Wait, let me see. Do you have a fucking dagger? You do. Okay.
I didn't see how much it was. How much is it?
400. Okay. I was about to drop 2000 for no reason.
99. Sleep tight. Don't let the madam bite. Just kidding. Let me bite.
I always wondered, what was this about? I never used it.
This one, like I know when you raid someone, like turns you into the host,
but does it like get rid of stuff? I don't know. And then this one as well.
You can like just, why would you want to do that?
You still look like a normal human. It's a troll item. Oh, it does get rid of your red aura?
That's funny. Hi, boo-me. Hi, boo-me.
Yeah, get your exercise. Nice job.
So like, am I the only person that can see him because he's technically not here?
But there's like just a bunch of shit in the library anyways.
It's really just like, is anybody like concerned about the absolutely gore that's in this room?
I'm really confused. Does nobody smell that? Yeah, it's Dungy.
And this guy doesn't do anything.
He just follows you around and leans against the thing and gives you a thing.
Gives you a e-boat. Look at his little hand. His little hands like holding on to him.
I know Rodericka can sense him.
Really, only the ones I can't, nobody, do you smell that? Well, you are kind of a skeleton
yourself, so maybe you don't smell that. Like, how he has that weapon as his weapon is the skeleton.
Gideon doesn't know where he is. He lives right now. Yeah, I'm like, I don't,
any, this whole place would smell like absolute shit.
Like, I don't, it's phantom, does that look like phantom poop to you?
Because like, he looks like phantom. This looks like real shit that I'm sloshing through
with real flies.
It's, yeah, shit and bodies.
The helmet protects tarnished from smells instead of head injuries, impressive.
Hiya, Boomi, what's up? Why are you trying to go for my feet?
That's the chain.
What? What do you want, Mr?
I think my headache medications make me sick.
Watch me, I've accidentally taken a Tylenol PM
so that was a horrible Tylenol, because I've done that before.
At least my head doesn't turn anymore.
So we're going to go...
Wait, where do I get quick step from?
Did you take earlier?
I'm 99% sure it's just normal ibuprofen. I'm just tired because I've been streaming since 130.
Have you seen a single toilet this whole game?
I'm pretty sure there is like an outhouse sort of thing.
Boomi, what are you up to? Is there something under my computer that you want?
You have a toy right there. He's just acting up.
The war master shack, yeah.
The dagger I just bought has quick step automatically.
Am I stupid?
I think I am. Anyways,
back to the cave. I feel like I'm very tired and I just want to remember you also.
I thought I had to get quick step.
Oh, it doesn't exactly have it.
That's not where I wanted to go.
I forgot you should probably like dodge the shit. Oh, like so.
I'm just like going through stuff. I'm not waiting for stuff to stop.
The head pat emo. I know I should get a head pat emo.
Oh, I keep going the wrong way.
That's the area of fucking Scarlet Rock.
Oh, I forgot the serpent bow is in here.
Oh, sorry.
I'm getting fucking terrified every time I see a
maiden. It's going to go this way really quick.
I don't think I went the right way. Oh, fun.
Ever get? Is there a grace?
No.
Raina, let's not hop up on my desk right now. Okay. You don't have to chirp at me.
Hi, Raina.
You have eye crusties.
There's a statue of America? I don't know. Is there?
Oh, Raina, you are hurting me with her. No, you can't.
She's like gripping my shoulders. I can't take her.
You're purring so hard. Raina, I need to put you on the ground.
Oh, all right. Well, I have a cat on me now. She is a cleaning baby, but I love her for that.
Oh, why did I go this way?
All right, tell me something. Just tell me that Boomi's going crazy right now.
Time to complete it in one go? Um, sure. I didn't. It's fine. Well, I shouldn't have done that.
Can you go after my other thing first?
Because I did shit wrong.
I accidentally gave him to the tagger.
Oh, no.
No. It's fine. It's fine.
Damn it. I feel like I could have gone that in one go.
I know I forgot to. I like walked in and I saw the dagger in my hand. I'm like, no.
I'm tired. That's my excuse. I'm tired.
Then I gotta do this shit. This will probably take me like one more.
I kind of sworn there was like a thing down here.
Come on. Come on. Come. No. Don't die. Don't die. No, don't.
Oh my god.
I think I need to go to bed after this.
That's the wrong way. Anyways, what am I doing? What am I stuck on?
Yeah.
Oh, wrong way. Oh, no.
Why don't you just go down? I'm gonna get poisoned.
Get out of the fucking way, bro. I have cat hair in my eye and Rena on my lap.
There's a rat.
I don't always got bit by a rat.
I don't know. I'm not just jumping over things.
No. Stop. No. Stop. Can you stop, please? I don't have any boluses for that. I'm just gonna die slowly.
Oh, this is great.
I just think I'd win if I walked in there.
I got poisoned grease.
I can wait.
Try to two hand the moon veil.
I'm literally gonna wait until this is done. Why is poison lasting forever?
I'm wondering if I should heal. Okay, then I might just heal and just go in and kill them.
Okay, yeah, I'm just gonna...
I call this one just like rises out of fucking nothing. You guys come over here.
Yeah, this is the same damage I'm doing.
Oh, I don't even think I needed him.
Use your fucking sword, bro.
I don't have any more. It's fine.
Yeah, I didn't even need the fucking mimic. I just grabbed the mimic just in case.
Oh my god, my eye hurts now.
I did not need the fucking mimic to heal for that.
Okay, I think it's time I go to bed. I'm still fucking poisoned.
Let me... So I got the golden scarab. I'm just gonna sit myself here.
I don't know why I need to get by fucking arrows.
I just want to set myself up for success. I think there was arrows. He had arrows.
I know it's almost over. No, it's not gonna be the perfect time. I'm not gonna be able to do this
fast enough. I'm already like freaking out.
Where's the dude? Oh no, where's the dude? He's over there.
No, I'm so tired. I also didn't sleep last night.
Hello. Hello.
Yeah, I didn't fall. Well, it's not like I don't stay up. I just don't fall asleep.
Those are bolts. I need arrows. It's like they know.
Well, I will take all of these. Thank you kindly. I think they know that we're gonna go see Moglin.
Moglin, Moglin. I don't need arrows for leveling.
Do I literally have just enough?
I do.
That's funny.
I need arrows for farming.
For a hug.
What? I'm so tired.
Yeah, I have a serpent bow.
Yeah, that's a great bow. This is normal bow. I know that the seeds are cane, but we really
don't need that for that. Is that anything on? Oh my god.
Fuck. I didn't equip arrows.
There. Whoopsies.
Nope. That's not what I want.
Is it? Oh, fuck. Hold on. Hold on.
Nope.
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about. I bought normal arrows. What are you talking about?
Why is it?
Why wasn't it?
That was weird.
I forgot how to use a bow for a second.
Hey, come on. Yeet.
Yes, it's me.
This is going to take a while.
This is going to take a while. Farming for levels.
I might do this actually before I go to bed.
I haven't caught an icy stream yet.
Is it really that down bad? I don't. What?
What is the context of that question? Back to you being past the practice of the end.
Thank you. Oh, good. I'm so proud.
You did great, which was a mob that I don't know. I'm scream. That would be funny.
No. Oh, my guts are a little bit longer.
Mow dies tomorrow. The tree has a weird hitbox. I usually just, I do it when they're in between
the tree. Oh.
That's, this is how you know how fucking tired I am, bro.
Okay, let me grab my runes. And let's look at my cute little, my cute little outfit, my cute little bow.
Greenies in my arms and my eyes are itchy because I think I got like a piece of cat hair
and I blame Reina. I'm going to go knock out.
Hawaii.
I'm asleep. I know my sleep schedule has been so bad lately, guys. I don't even mean it to be,
even Boomi's coming over right now. He's like, come on. And then Reina just huffed at him.
She goes, and that's this morning.
We'll be right at the cause. Oh, perhaps, maybe just a little bit because I need to, I just
like staying up and spending time with you. Oh, me. Save.
I don't know why you don't want you to meet me. Oh, I'm like off to the side. Do I have any orders
for you tonight? Sleep well. I want you to, why are you asking me to tell you to do stuff when I'm
half asleep right now? I'm like, I'm falling asleep in my chair. Reina, I'm not open.
I want you to get yourself a cat boy outfit and dress up as a little cat. No, I'm kidding. Please
don't do that. Remember when I'm sleepy and my voice gets high?
Boomi,
you're planning a buying cat boy outfit. Anyway, it is for one reason.
Um, I don't know. I just hope you guys sleep well.
Over six hours. That's, I'm impressed with your attention span because I wouldn't be able to
watch myself for six hours. Jesus Christ. Oh, but thank you guys for hanging out with me all day.
Like, oh my gosh, or stopping by if you could. Um,
Reina, stop being so cute with your big eyes.
I wish I didn't have to work. Oh,
get some rest. I will.
Boomi, do you just kick glitter onto my computer?
Boomi, you're gonna mess up. I'm trying to time this properly.
It would be at 10, 10. She'd be marathon streamer. I don't mean to. I just like it.
Errah. What's fun popping in for a bit of beginning in meow. Yeah, thank you guys for stopping by,
stopping in, saying hi. And then we're stopping in, stopping by, saying hi.
Oh, maybe I'll, that'll be my outro for streams. Um, can we get, can we get a pet the madam emote?
No, you don't get to make demands of me. Excuse you. More Elden Ring tomorrow. Yes,
I'll probably stream early again. Actually, I do have to record a special ASMR.
And Boomi never, although he's finally actually laid in the bed. Like as I'm getting off,
now he wants to be comfy and cute in the bed. If he did it sooner, I would have put the cat cam on.
Because I like cat cam for long streams.
Um, but,
because I already ordered emotes, so I can't like just add another emote to it.
So that'll take a while if I do that. Um, because I didn't, did I add a pat emote?
I can't remember, because I had 10 emotes that I got that I could order. Um, Strani was telling me, so.
I missed, I see barrier stream didn't work, so it was good to still like, yeah, yeah.
Um, I'm sorry you missed your stream.
Of the recording, did you forget if I have to make a cover? Yeah, covers are hard to make. I'm happy that
like, Strani was pretty concise in what she wanted from us and being like, okay, do it like this.
I'm like, okay. And it worked out and it sounded at least a little bit of okay.
I think my bathroom fan is broken because it sounds like it's rattling.
Okay. I was getting distracted by things when I'm like falling asleep in my chair.
What do you have to pay to do covers? Um, like, well, we don't get like any copyright because
we didn't claim copyright or like, you just, if you're okay with not getting the money, then you
just like, you can go through the artist and ask for permission only if you want to monetize it.
We didn't monetize any of our music videos so they can't get claimed.
Yeah, no, I did not pay Ray William Johnson to sing his song.
That would be very cool though, but I'm not making any money off of singing his song. So
favorite line from your cover.
Butter ass was looking good up in the mom jeans.
Or the, or the, I approached her in the checkout line and said, oh, yeah. Oh, baby, what's up?
Yo, baby, what's up? That was pretty good.
Maybe the girls out. Stop. Don't look at them. Stop. Stop staring. Why are you pointing it out?
Why are you pointing it out, bro? You're making it weird.
Frick, it's 1012. Oh, you guys tricked me.
I'm easily distracted when I'm tired.
I love how my eyes glow.
Don't you have to go through the music labels to get permission to monetize the music?
I just said that. You have to go through the artists. If you want to monetize it,
none of our stuff is monetized.
Man, I will stay longer the more we talk. Shut up.
Yep. 1015.
Even. What's everyone doing?
No, you don't have to. No, I did not. No, not like that.
Tell us about the boy. No, I still have to watch the episode after this and I'm not going to make
it. So I'll probably watch it tomorrow morning. I have to go grocery shopping. Maybe I will go
grocery shopping just for a couple of days so I can have a couple of days worth of food instead
of ordering DoorDash. I'll get some uncrossibles. Is my favorite person in the boys? None of them.
I think every character has a hateable trait. Besides Kimiko.
So I guess Kimiko is my least hated character. I literally just looked at the talk of the time
because I'm like, it's a 17. Okay.
Girl, please stop. I hate everyone except you, I guess. Yeah, friend Jesus is annoying sometimes.
He just was like, I'm like, why do you, why do you do this? Why do you do stupid stuff? Even MMM?
Uh, MMM, everybody makes stupid decisions because I hate all of them because they're very human.
Excuse me. Oh no, I didn't mute. I'm being taken advantage of on my eepiness.
I'm leaving. Goodnight.
Why are you lying about my burp? Wait, where's my BGM? Where's my BGM? My BGM? I'm getting bigger.
No, I don't mean to be changing my model.
Okay, there's my BGM. BGM good. BGM's good. I'm over tired.
I'm gonna mute the desktop audio and close up other things. And then...
Hi. Bye. Oh, it's 10.15. Bye. Bye. I gotta go. I gotta end it. I gotta stop streaming.